e
good morning everyone and welcome to the
house committee on Health and Human
Services and elderly Affairs we have an
executive session scheduled for this
morning and hearings scheduled for this
afternoon uh before we get to any of
that however I'd ask you to please join
Allegiance I pledge allegiance to the
flag of the United States of America and
to the Republic for which it stands one
nation under God indivisible
all thank you
everyone okay as noticed uh the first um
Bill listed today uh for consideration
and executive session is Senate Bill 349
representative kushman did you have a
motion yes uh I move itl on this bill
and I can second that uh would you like
to speak to your motion sure thank you
um so the council um is already in
existence and they do collaborate with
uh medical professionals already and we
have the commission to study the primary
Workforce and um state of rural Health
in New Hampshire at this time and we
just added a member of um direct
Frontier to that commission uh to bring
the free market perspective of direct
Primary Care Providers um we also have a
growing
um Market of postpartum doulas that
offer support to women postpartum and
can refer for care um typically women
have follow-ups with their Physicians
after they give birth and I think that
um especially with the this new uh
direct Primary Care market and the
growing Midwifery and Doula um provider
base uh that we have in New Hampshire
and you know we already have these
studies on it it's uh it's a little bit
of a jump for the council to be uh going
into this so I I would uh I would
suggest that it's not the time it's a
little too soon um and it's not
appropriate and also the um we should it
kind of undermines community um instead
of sending mandated reporters into
people's homes we should be encouraging
people to reach out to their supports
that they have um and not kind of I
understand that it says voluntary right
now um but I just see it as kind of
putting a nose Under the Tent to kind of
creeping into people's homes so that's
all thank you thank you I'm
representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman I'm sorry
that I'm not going to be able to go
along with that as I read the bill um it
is a report to give us a good idea of
where we are now and it's fine to say
we've have all of these things but the
question is whether people are actually
accessing them or not and whether there
are barriers to access that ought to be
removed um and I want to make it very
clear that the program itself is
entirely voluntary so nobody goes to
anybody's home unless they are invited
and if somebody does not participate in
the program they won't be subject to the
report so to say that this creates
people going into people's h Homes and
Reporting is a real
stretch and as we
know every new year is a new year and
every new legislator and halfway through
we all have an opportunity to change
everything so uh to say that one bill is
going to lead to others and others
others is
is
um true but it's true for every single
Bill we pass uh finally I would say that
I would hope that in the event this
report shows that we have needs that are
being unmet in terms of home
visits after a pregnancy to support a
new mother which is something that I
think we should all be very much in
favor of particularly as it's voluntary
and not
mandatory um is something we ought to be
encouraging as a legislature and not not
um putting roadblocks so I want to be
sure that we study whether there are
roadblocks and and how we could perhaps
make services available to all who want
them if in fact there are people who
want them now and are not getting them
which I don't know
because hasn't been studied yet thank
Merchant thank you Mr
chair initially I was looking at the
bill and one of the things that I saw
was it's not mandatory it's truly
voluntary and as a legislator one of the
things I've come to realize is the lack
of information to make good
policy and lacking that information
becomes critical when we're trying to
make policy decisions here in the
legislative body by colle cting the data
and collecting the information which is
again voluntary it helps Drive good
decision- making by legislative people
like myself and everyone else around
this room so I would be opposed to the
itl I would definitely want to support
the
ogp other discussion representative
kushman thank you Mr chairman um I have
some problems with who is on this
Council making these recommendations in
this report I think there's a lot of
conflict of interest because many of the
enti on this Council receive federal
funds for increasing um cases of
domestic violence um petitions to Family
Court to remove children from homes I
think that they are way too embedded in
the system that goes in and corrects
when there are problems in families and
Social Services for them to be uh
deciding whether that this program
should go forward and doing this report
I think that it's going to come out
biased
and therefore I I don't think it's
appropriate for this Council to do it
um I think it would be more appropriate
for the primary Workforce Council to do
it or DHHS to send out a voluntary
survey survey to new parents after they
have a baby and then a report can be
issued by DHHS and they can do that
without this Bill thank you
representative L do you want to speak uh
yes thank you Mr chairman uh sorry I was
introducing a bill so if any of this has
already been tread let me know um and
some of my research um we don't
necessarily have the data on New
Hampshire about how the different
implications of um DCF and and Child
Protection impact People based on income
levels but when we look at some of the
work that's been done in other states
they adver they impact people with lower
incomes at a much higher rate partially
because higher income people can better
represent themselves and uh I just as we
look at all of this we need to look at
all of all of these different factors
because I don't think it's a problem in
New Hampshire but I don't know if it's a
problem in New Hampshire so until we can
have an idea if there is an income
linked issue like they have in New York
and in other states we just want to make
sure that we're not creating more of
these interactions in a vulnerable time
um but more importantly the primary care
Workforce can look at this and can work
on this and um I I I think that as we
look at our limited resources we make
sure that we use these limited resources
wisely
representative uh Murphy thank you Mr
chairman um I also will vote um against
the itl motion and in part of it is that
number one new Futures supports this
bill number two DHHS supports this bill
um that was the Bureau of family health
and nutrition um it does provide data I
think the primary care Workforce is
overworked at this point in right time
right now and if we have the data that
would be available it would be very
helpful but also to me the current
situation is somewhat discriminatory in
that only Medicaid patients right now to
qualify for home access for you know to
assess the the the status of their
newborn and their mom's care so for all
those reasons I would vote against the
it motion I don't believe it's perfect I
don't believe also that it will lead to
further um uh problems down the road but
having said that you know the the
primary care Workforce currently is uh
overburdened and I don't think we can
simply put upon them to check to make
sure that the home health of um a
newborn and a mother is um is done so I
will vote against the itl motion at this
point Thank you thank you uh
representative
tez thank you Mr chairman and uh uh
thank you representative Lon for
reminding us that there is a need for
data um until that the study and report
is issued we don't know if there's um
disparate uh anything uh by income level
uh I would second representative
Murphy's comment this actually does not
belong in the purview of the primary
care uh Workforce legislative commission
and um you know there is a maternal
mortality crisis and US ranks really
poorly uh compared to other countries
and home visiting is a proven method for
improving maternal and infant Health um
I would say uh since this is just to get
data and information
and provide a report so we can then
figure out is there a need what are the
needs um to me this is a very uh uh
obvious thing that I would think we
would all be in agreement
about representative
Shapero yes thank you Mr chairman um I
know on this committee and in general in
the legislature and in our country we
have
um competing strongly held um feelings
um but my sense is that people on both
sides of that issue speak about the
importance of supporting young families
and supporting children who are born um
into difficult situations and um so I
see this as kind of a pro-life Bill
where we're doing everything we can to
encourage help for for people who are um
bringing children into the world and
creating new families and
um I'm not sure how we veered off in
this discussion about people being
reported to DCF and having their
children removed but I don't think that
that's the focus of this bill or this
effort um to encourage help for people
who voluntarily accept that help um so I
will definitely vote against the it
and um support a different motion thank
you any other
discussion representative
Palmer I just wanted to speak um in a
positive way I'm I'm opposed to the itl
um there was a program that did exactly
this in Claremont in the mid 90s and it
was I think a collaboration of the city
and the school and the hospital I don't
remember the details it was extremely
popular with the parents and a lot of
these young kids getting them early
access to both health care and books and
all kinds of things and then the funding
run ran out and so I would really want
to see some study into how something
like this could be supported because
it's not necessarily just a health care
issue it's there are a lot of aspects to
it that could be very
positive thank you any other uh
representative Tes yeah uh thank you Mr
chairman so to to add on um I've been
participating in uh work with new
mothers uh and have heard from many of
them that um in the current times people
don't have the kind of community
supports that maybe we used to and so
this would not supplant something this
is because those supports don't
currently exist the way we used to our
family structures aren't the same as
they used to be our communities are not
the same as they used to be and so many
moms even from different income levels
feel very alone they feel um that it's
hard to get the support that they need
even to just understand like the kinds
of questions that arise or the kinds of
concerns that arise and so just being
able to have someone who is assigned to
you as someone who can be a support and
help get mothers through that first year
postpartum which is when we're seeing um
deaths related to substance abuse deaths
all sorts of other
um reasons why people who aren't
connected are are dying or they're just
um no one sees that they're having
difficulties and issues and they're not
connected to care when they need to be
so home visiting is a very well-proven
uh methodology for supporting maternal
and child health and making them um more
likely to thrive and be successful and
healthy and contributing members of
society
other discussion representative
frus I just would like to add that I
think that um I will vote against itl I
have been in have known some people who
have done these voluntary in home
visiting and they find lots of things
and a lot of support for these young
mothers who don't know what they what
they're doing right at that point so I
think that itl is not good thank you
thank
you uh represenative Coachman thank you
I just want to read some of the entities
that if home visits are increased may be
finding themselves getting increased
State contracts if they are the ones who
are writing this report and they
encourage more State entities to go in
there it's possible that they will be
growing the amount of federal funding
and state funding they receive through
contracts with the state New Futures the
New Hampshire Coalition against domestic
and sex ual violence um the New
Hampshire um DCF all of those will be
getting increased
funding if you bring them into people's
homes and until there's due process
within some of these entities I think
that is not a safe thing to be bringing
in government entities at a at a
vulnerable time in people's
lives especially if they're the ones
writing the report if someone else was
going to be writing the report who was
not involved in government contracts I
might be open to it but it's not a an
unbiased entity a unbiased group of
people who are doing this there are many
who are have conflicts of interest and
are on all different kinds of boards and
we see that they generate a lot of
revenue for themselves and I would like
to see unbiased Research into this not
these government
contractors representative
Weber the only answer to that is that
neither DCF nor the Coalition against
domestic or sexual violence have
anything to do with a voluntary home
visiting
program the intent of which is to
ensure that those kind of interventions
are not going be necessary in this
family that's item number one item
number two a report with data is
collected a recommendation may or may
not be made and then every member of
this body gets to decide whether we need
to file a bill or not and it gets the
same process as everybody else so um I
think
that people are frightened of things
that simply don't exist with respect to
this program
um any other discussion representative
Tes yeah I I want to add on to what
representative Weber said which is that
neither of those entities nor um new
Futures are people who do home visiting
home visiting falls under the Maternal
Child Health um uh section in the uh
division of Public Health services
within DHHS there's a whole maternal
infant and early childhood home visiting
program they're part of Healthy Families
new um America there there there there's
it's a whole different sector unto
itself um and it and it's has nothing to
do with those entities and also I think
that when a report is written it doesn't
mean that the stakeholders who maybe
they'll issue an RFP maybe they'll hire
a researcher like I think that we're
jumping to conclusions about um uh how
the methodology for how the report will
be written and then again seconding that
these are not the people who do
visiting representative Lon um thank you
very much and I want to thank my
colleagues for bringing up a very very
important Point um the Coalition against
Domestic and Sexual Violence is not
involved in home visiting new Futures is
not involved in in home visiting uh Nami
is not involved in home visiting law
enforcement offers are not involved in
home visiting the president of family
support New Hampshire maybe I'm not sure
uh the New Hampshire children's trust I
don't think they are the New Hampshire
early childhood advisory Council May the
division of Public Health Services um
would uh the DCF we heard is not the
Department of Education is not the
Department of Corrections is not um one
member of the house is and one member of
the Senate is that is the makeup of the
well wellness and primary prevention
Council that does not seem to be a
council that is aligned with home visits
um after birth in these in these early
vulnerable times this is not the right
group to do this that is the makeup of
that of that Council and it does not
seem like an appropriate
tasking okay representative TZ and then
I'd like to move to a vote if we could
yes s just last comment sorry uh thank
you I I think representative Weber made
the point which is all the entities you
mentioned actually have a very strong
interest in
preventing the need for Nami Mental
Health Services the need for DCF and so
they are very interested in the topic
and that's why they're uh issuing the
recommendation that there be a report so
that then uh future um efforts can be
directed appropriately okay thank you
all right with that I'll I'll ask
collector call a the motion is uh itl on
Senate Bill
349 representative Lon yes
representative kushman yes cler votes
yes representative mlan
yes representative Seth King
yes representative Missour
yes representative bogert
yes representative POF
yes representative Weber
no representative McKay no
Representative fedus no representative
Canon
no representative upam no representative
Shapiro no representative Merchant no
representative Murphy
no representative Palmer no
representative TZ No and representative
McDonald yes 10 to 10 motion does not
pass do I have another motion
representative
Weber I move out to
pass second representative Merchant
seconds is there any other discussion on
this think we've covered it okay
whenever the clock is ready a motion is
349 representative Leon
no Representative kushman no clerk votes
no Representative kofalt
no Representative mlan no representative
Seth King no representative Missour
no Representative bogert
no representative POF no representative
Weber yes representative McKay yes
representative Fus yes representative
Canon yes representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro yes
representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer yes represent TZ yes and
represent McDonald no 10 to
10 and that'll go to the floor with no
recommendation uh and just as a reminder
as we proceed uh on on these bills as
always we need the reports soon as
possible to make it in for next week's
calendar so thank you everyone uh next
up is a house excuse me Senate Bill p52
FNA we have already discussed that and
EXA that last week um so we don't need
to consider that this this morning uh
next up after that is Senate Bill 357
and representative Canon I believe you
have an amendment I have an amendment
yes
everybody had a chance to review the
amendment representative um was that
that was seconded right was it
representative Mery I don't I don't
think anybody's moved it just passed all
right sorry um do you want to move your
Amendment representative um I'd like to
move uh I I to pass on Amendment 20
24 1696 h
second that okay representative Le on
seconds would You' like to speak to your
motion sure um when we were discussing
this bill in committee um it was we were
all seemed to be in favor of adding
position assistance uh the question that
was said how do we how do we determine
uh who's the primary care or private uh
primary or primarily was uh discussed as
the as the issue and a number of folks
worked on this and uh so I wasn't on the
initial uh team that was working on it
however as I uh was presented with this
in discussion with uh The Honorable
Jerry kerk um we recognized that there
is a there is a challenge in trying to
determine who's the primary uh person
that would sign off on uh on
uh the uh the information to to uh
prescribed the uh
cannabis and um and then I thought to
myself I said I I have a similar
situation a few years ago I had to get a
uh a therapeutic cannabis card and when
I when I went to get a signature I said
who do I go to um I have my PCP my
endocrinologist my neurologist my
psychologist and my cardiologist and
each of them had their own opinion and
of whether I should or not in almost all
every case they said sounds like a good
idea but in each one of them it was
their a primary care in their own
field uh so there wasn't one primary um
so this this inclusion of U paragraph F
number five was to um essentially make
sure that we people have the right
credentials to prescribe and that's what
this amendment is about is to clarify
that
position thank you representative Leon
uh thank you Mr chairman and thank you
representative Canon for for taking this
I know that you were involved in the
initial bill that died in the committee
of conference last year and I'm glad
we're following up on this um so this
the biggest issue was around the word
primarily and at least one member um
over on the other body was very
concerned about that language um so
there was work that was done and um they
reached out to um the medical director
and Board of Medicine representative um
about this idea primarily responsible
and he said when a patient is admitted
to the hospital there is a physician of
record that is primarily responsible for
the care of the patient and the
Specialists provide advice and provide
notes back to the physician who is
primarily responsible to oversee the
patients's overall care this is similar
to the primary care provider on the
outpatient side for this legislation it
does not seem applicable
um because in this legislation it's not
about uh hospitalization or any other
specific event that was my commentary
adding so going back to his language he
says it's hard to determine who is
primarily responsible for any one
condition sometimes it's a PCP sometimes
it's a specialist such as a pain
management Specialist or psychiatrist
who's treating the qualifying condition
removing primarily or keeping it doesn't
make much difference um so that supports
this move to remove that word primarily
because as we've seen in the other
legislation and the more difficult it is
to understand the harder it is to
implement so this is I think good and
clean and I just want to note this this
amendment still keeps our initial issue
of making sure that it doesn't have to
be a pediatrician for a child it just
has to be the provider providing their
care so I think this is an important and
necessary step so thank
you representative
Weber I just wanted to say that I'm I'm
really struck by the
S the Brilliance of just tying it
the carer to the person who is treating
the underlying prescription for which
the therapeutic cannabis is needed so
the the relationship there is good and
tight and um I just wanted to say thank
you to everybody who worked on
this and representative Merchant I also
want to say thank you to representative
Canon um particularly lines 13-
16 which is more of a catchall and part
of it we normally don't think about
naturopathic doctors which also could
provide some level of primary care and
since they actually have the ability to
prescribe control drugs it allows them
to do the same thing so having that
there I think is very important thank
you other
discussion seeing none okay the motion
is ought to pass on uh Amendment 2024
hyen 169 96 H to Amendment uh to excuse
me to Senate Bill
357 when the clerk is ready I'll ask him
to call the role representative Lan yes
representative kushman yes clerk votes
yes representative kofalt yes
representative mlan yes representative
Seth King yes representative Missour yes
representative Boger yes representative
POF yes representative Weber yes
representative McKay yes representative
fedus yes representative Canon yes
representative Nutter upam yes
representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant
yes representative Murphy yes
representative Palmer yes representative
TZ yes and represent McDonald yes 20 to
nothing motion pass passes okay do I
have another
motion representative
Canon I move the uh aop pass on Senate
Bill 357 as amended by 2024
169h representative Leon representative
Lon seconds any other
discussion representative Seth King
thank you Mr chair um I just want to
thank um Representatives Ganon and
representatives Lon for the amendment um
I would just my hope is that I don't
know how the other body is going to take
that Amendment My Hope Is that they're
open to it um and my admonition would be
not to budge on it at all because my
concern is that in the attempt to expand
the number of caregivers if we leave
that primarily in there we might
actually be reducing the number of
potential caregivers so um I hope we
don't budge on that when it comes time
for that thanks thank you
representative Merchant just as an FYI
the federal department of justice is
working the DEA to reschedule from
schedule one schedule three if that
happens then you can prescribe it
anyways I saw that
yeah any other
discussion seeing none um I'll ask the
cler to call the all the motion is out
to pass as amended on Senate Bill
357 representative Lon yes yes
representative kushman yes cler votes
yes representative kofalt
yes representative mlan yes
representative Seth King
yes representative Missour yes
representative
bogert
yes representative POF yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative fedus yes
representative Canon yes representative
nut
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
represent
Murphy yes representive Palmer
yes representive TZ yes and represent
McDonald yes 20 to zero motion passes
okay if there's no objection
consent okay great all right moving on
uh next up is Senate Bill 402 and pres
Merchant I believe you have an amendment
yeah that's not the one you mentioned to
me earlier is it or is it no okay this
is the one trying to correct the U
language in the bill there one missing
SC
that was the only change is the the
punctuation or the punctuation plus the
fact is on lines 13 through 16 was
deleting it's redundant okay so it takes
care of the
redundancy you want to move this
amendment representative yes please yes
okay is there a second second
representative Weber seconds
okay do you wish to speak to it further
representative Merchant yes
please the bill came over to us from the
Senate and during the testimony um the
hearing if you will it was determined
that there was a period after the line
11 available to the general public
that's current law and by putting the
comma in there it kind of confused many
things so I reinserted the period after
the the word public to separate the two
so today under current law we can
provide covid vaccine as well as
influenza by a certified tech a licensed
pharmacy tech a pharmacist or a pharmacy
intern after that was also looking at
lines 11 it was confusing because the
Way It Was Written was allowing the
certifi Texs to give the vaccines which
is not current law so by taking out the
reference on lines 13
through 16 which is really redundant is
saying that the FDA approves the
vaccines and it's not prohibited by the
CDC as being against the administration
of the vaccine then the pharmacist would
at that point in time have the authority
to provide it to the patient as well as
to administer it so it's more of a
grammatical it's trying to clean up the
language more than anything else
representative Weber
and if you note on line 11 of the
amendment um in the original bill they
had stricken out the providers and left
half of a sentence dangling there so um
Mrs Casey who always comes into my brain
when we have sentences that aren't
complete or have dangling modifiers or
something like that is much happier
today than she was when we saw the
original Bill Mrs Casey was that your
high school English teacher or uh yes
okay it was it would be called middle
school now
junor other
discussion seeing none representative
Leon uh thank you Mr chairman and thank
you representative Merchant for bringing
this um I see that initially um this had
been for vaccines licensed by the FDA
that are recommended by the CDC and asip
um and I see that the amend Amendment
changes it to an FDA approved vaccine as
ordered by the IM immunizing pharmacists
provided that the CDC doesn't recommend
against administration of the vaccine so
that also seems to be a Content change
and I'm just curious about a little bit
more that was in the original bill that
came over from the Senate so it kept the
same language it came over from the
Senate from Senator bisell um thank you
I I actually pulled up what we have as
amended from the Senate and um I guess
let me make sure that I clicked on the
right link opening this up but the
when I let's see as I see that language
um you may have been working on the
under the bill before it was amended by
the Senate um because that language is
see yes you went back to um the language
changed is that was that has the Senate
amended it yes the Senate amended um
some of that language um so that it
would read um differently um
so the Senate as they amended it and
sent it to us um if we were to put it
this way it would say that the
pharmacist Pharmacy intern or licensed
Advanced pharmacy technician under the
supervision of an on-site immunizing
pharmacist May administer uh vaccines
licensed by the US FDA that are
recommended by the US CDC and and the a
IP or successor organization to
individuals 18 years of older is ordered
by an immunizing
pharmacist and that it has the
requirements in there representative
Weber I'm wondering if having discovered
that discrepancy we might want to put
this one off till next week so we could
have an amendment that conforms to the
bill as passed by the Senate because I
don't think that it's productive for us
to
introduce uh something that's going to
upset at the apple cart to the extent
that it might and I do want to apologize
to representative Merchant for not
reading through the amendment when you
sent the language
yesterday no problem I didn't do the
same
so okay
so we want to continue 402 is what I'm
hearing and I'll if it's okay with the
committee I want to be sure that at this
point in time the goal is to take what
was in the Senate that came over to us
and just changed the language to what
was
there so okay we agree does that
representative L does that sound that
okay like what your suggest all right
I'll change it okay great thank you all
right we'll continue I'll withdraw my
I'll withdraw my motion on the amendment
if the second will withdraw theirs okay
absolutely okay thank you all right uh
so the amendment is withdrawn and we
will continue uh Senate Bill 402 to next
Wednesday next up is Senate Bill
458 and um representative Merchant I
once again you have an
this is the one we were talking about
earlier yeah about the N gerain is there
any no mind I was trying to think about
402 if I sent it over to OS quickly if I
could get it back but tomorrow next
week's fine it's not early bill right
the early bills are over okay yep than
you yes okay we've done the early bills
okay and where is off and we had a
committee caucus the Republicans had a
committee caucus earlier and we we were
suspecting this might get continued to
next week anyway so so yeah we need to
uh schedule a non-gain hearing according
to the clerk's office on this that was
the advice the clerk gave us I gave
myself which I'm passing on to the
committee okay and his rationale was the
fact that
even though the change is in RSA 318 the
change that I'm proposing is in a
different section of 318 therefore it
good and what it
basically the quandry we're in so to
speak is the fact that in the RSA
31837 if references
retail which is the old definition ofes
phes historically always been in the
retail sector and so forth during that
time we've had now phes that evolved
into nuclear pharmacies home infusion
pharmacies long-term care pharmacies now
we're talking about an in-house Clinic
Pharmacy by taking out that reference to
the quote retail sector it allows the
Board of Pharmacy at that point in time
to issue a permit and based upon how the
owner of that permit wants to utilize
that permit would drive what rules and
regulations they comply with so they can
create they be in the board simple rules
for in-house Pharmacy that want to
provide medications to the patient by
doing it that way it allows all medical
providers not just oncologists to go to
the board and at that point in time
request a dispensing
license um it's comparable to what we
see in States of Virginia North Dakota
South
Carolina North Carolina and Florida so
it's not a precedent that's actually
been done in other states throughout the
country so my talking with the
um representatives of the underlying um
request the client they do have Pharmacy
Personnel it's not like we're asking
them to hire a pharmacist they actually
have them on
staff at the same time it allows the
patient then to pick up all of the
medications not just part of it because
if you only can do oncolytics then you
got to get into the definition what's an
oncolytic then you get into the issue
what do you do with the medications for
no vomiting what do you do with
medications with what they call EG
junctive therapy then you're forcing the
patient to go to multiple locations to
get their drug therapy versus it truly
being an integrated model which we're
trying to get to so they have One-Stop
shopping secondly by building it through
the pharmacy benefit side the patient
knows at that point in time what their
financial responsibility is if it goes
into the medical side of the equation a
lot of times the patients don't know
that afterwards and you get what to call
a medical surprise so it really kind of
allows for the clinic
to bring it internal an in-house
Pharmacy what I call a mini Pharmacy
actually it was do um rips and Lon which
I think is what we're trying to get to
so they have the ability to dispense and
that license is under the Board of
Pharmacy it allows them also at the same
time there's no restrictions on 30-day
Supply
90day Supply they can do control drugs
so they have access to everything so the
patient truly can have One-Stop shopping
that's kind of the important part here
is that the patient doesn't have to go
to multiple
locations okay thank
you representative
Weber and I would just add a a couple of
things I mean it seems to me that this
really solves a bunch of problems
because it um once it seems to me that
once we approve something specific
specifically for oncologics then we will
be in that position that we all
recognize of having the next Clinic come
in and want different kinds of
prescribing and I just wanted to also so
this is a way of making it clear because
some people already thought that the
pharmacy board had jurisdiction over
this but the pharmacy board was
unwilling so it makes it clear that what
the pharmacy board's jurisdiction is and
then the regulation can stay where it
ought to be with the people who regulate
the dispensing of controlled
substances and and finally I just wanted
to make one remark about the um duration
of time
limitation I know people were concerned
about uh DHHS were concerned about the
Medicaid requiring uh that things be
dispensed in 30-day increments but the
fact is that everybody's Healthcare have
just run up against it with treatment
for dry
eye everybody's coverage and and amount
of dosage is um governed by what your
insurance company is going to pay for
and the practices are very clear about
who pays for what and how long and
that's what the the provider then writes
the prescription for so I don't see a
purpose for limiting it specifically in
the statute because one
source of remuneration only writes for
30 days or or only goes for 30 days
representative Shapiro thank you Mr
chairman um I think this is um good
because it puts oversight of um
dispensing medications under the Board
of Pharmacy um and the way I understood
it it wasn't that way with the infusion
treatments
um and I also understand that that
perhaps this could have been done prior
but the pharmacy board wasn't clear that
they could do that what I'm not clear
about is how this small change in
language clar clarifies the situation
and makes it clear
that now there will be able to be um
maybe
um dispensaries at these doctor's
um offices at these clinics but with
less um onerous regulations than a
retail pharmacy could so could you
explain just how this particular
language um makes that
clear yes represent SPL and looking at
the advisory that came opinion that came
from the Board of Pharmacy there was
concern over
the language in
31837 that it references retail and
therefore what the Board of Pharmacy and
haven't been on the board for 10 years
myself has trying to find creative ways
to allow for different uses of
permit again the same thing when you
have long-term care pharmacies you have
what they're call Central fill phes the
board was in a situation trying to be
creative as much as it could within the
confines of the law so by taking out any
reference the retail and just say the
board of farmacy has the ability to
issue a permit and then the permit
would be controlled by the rules and
regulations created by the Board of
Pharmacy for that practice setting so if
it's going to go into a central fill
pharmacy then those rules and
regulations hospitals for instance we
had to look at it for hospitals that
wanted to provide take home medications
to their patients well the board said we
could do it for one time only you
couldn't do a refill on it and that made
sense but this allows us to take out
that constraint called retail which is
the
Genesis of the pharmacy profession
historically it just makes it a little
clear to the board that the permit is
location response I'm just a one
followup I'm just wondering since my
understanding is that this is not an
official um Amendment I'm wondering if
we could get um like a straw poll about
whether the concept is um um supported
by the committee at some point before we
finish okay again it's being continued
anyway but um but representative Leon
you wanted to comment uh yes uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you representative
Merchant for working towards um making
this be a process that works I continue
to have the concern that with only
taking out the for sale of retail that
we may not be creating many pharmacies
we may be creating another large one and
that may not happen now but it may
happen in the future when we're not
around to make sure that that legisl
ative intent for many pharmacies that
are narrowly focused um with both the
powers and the requirements narrowly
focused to the needs of these different
providers is honored um I I really see
this as an oral par issue because with
the infusion products the doctors are
able to do this because that is one of
the things that is their is their
regular care as these oncologists and
these infusion clinics and oral par is
that now there are there are pills that
do a similar thing to what these
infusions had done um this is something
that representative Merchant worked very
hard on and got some great legislation
passed to make sure that our other
treatment of this would work for oral
parity and it seems to me that um these
providers are looking just for similar
parody so I before we even look to
having something that allows them to
have animedics and all of these other
categories of these supportive drugs
those are the antia drugs um before we
start looking at all of those we should
figure out how to craft something that
is narrow perhaps this should be based
on request to the Board of Pharmacy by a
particular practice so that they can ask
for the narrow procedures that they need
we need to make sure that we have enough
guard rails that as we draft the as uh
as they draft the administrative rules
we're able to do that and make sure that
it stays appropriately limited to scope
but um we're going to need to add some
sort of legislative intent or something
else or specific language to make sure
that we're doing this as something
that's small and streamlined as opposed
to opening something up up that we'll
have more options but then we'll come
with more um more bureaucracy oversight
and complications when it might just be
easier to have them stop by and do the
drive-through at CVS for those other
drugs if it means that they're better
able to provide these I'm just looking
to figure out how to lower the burden
overall and I appreciate what
representative Merchant has done um and
I think that it may actually make sense
as well to go back to this original part
about the 30-day Supply or moving it
down to a 30 it started at 90 the Senate
sent us at to us at 60 then there's the
idea of moving to 30 because that has
more acceptance um I think that putting
that into language that would be in
effect until the until the rules are
adopted and until it's a certain period
of time after the rules so that the that
these pharmacies actually can be created
would be key because um I actually
didn't realize until we started this
discussion that there's any independent
oncologists because all of them have at
least some relationships with the
hospitals but they New Hampshire
hematology and oncology does actually
have an independent office even though
they have these other relationships and
I think that we need to make sure that
we're fostering as much Independence in
healthcare as possible um especially as
we're starting to move to Big Medicine
all hospital-based and there's benefits
to that but it's also nice to have the
other side of the independent so I'm
really thankful that you're bringing
this forward and we're going to have a
non- derain Amendment heing on this so
that we can get this
right Thank You R Le be more than glad
to uh work work with you on language for
an
amendment sounds like this needs to go a
little further before ready free Min
pole representative Shapiro but good
suggestion any other thoughts on 458
again we're going to continue it till
next week anyway but um any thoughts
before we move
on seeing none
okay uh next up is uh Senate Bill 559
FN and representative Merchant I hear
you have an amendment on that also
well Le is going to go out of business
if let me do mine I
o sty this this is not the amendment I
this official no no I don't have the
actual official amendment I only have
the language that gave to OS so I can't
Forward they may have sent it to me this
morning
okay if they have I can upstairs and get
it
failing that I have the one that bu of
yours we can move on to 560 and then go
back to 559 if that's think gra that
Weber also has another amendment that
you want well let's let's wait and see
if yours is is available I also have
another amendment that uh all of these
amendments are attempts to deal
with the breadth of language so people
might want to consider all of them but
the the Amendments I have with the real
one not the fake one um is upstairs on
level four so I can go pick up the deck
cets thanks so do we want to what would
be the mood of the committee recess
briefly or you want
to glad to take take we'll take a 5
minute
recess
e
watch
I
can I'd like to thank you Mr I'd like to
call us back into session representative
Merchant I'll make a motion
to
pass sorry Amendment 2024 1710 which is
an amendment to Senate Bill
559 do I have a
second second representative waro
seconds would you like to speak to your
motion thank you Mr chair
the intent of the amendment was to
narrow down the issue of biological
products I heard from the committee
there was concerns about it being
somewhat broad to include exactly what
was being requested which is the RSV um
monoclonal
antibody it's technically not a a
vaccine It's actually an immunization so
we may have to go back and change the
wording to comply with the federal
statute in order for us to get the
funding we need but the intent of it
that I have here was
to take only RSV and make that the only
addition to the list and I get into
opening up potentially a larger
opportunity for other monoclonal
antibodies to be introduced in the
vaccine registry so that was the intent
of the amendment but in talking with the
Department just now the way I wrote it
is probably not going to be sufficient
to comply with the federal statute so I
may have to come back to the committee
next week with something else but before
I do that it' be nice to have a straw
poll with you folks here today to find
out if I have support from this
committee to modify the amendment so it
complies with the federal requirements I
don't want to hold up this committee if
the committee ultimately is not in favor
of an amendment regardless of how we
word it if the committee is in favor of
the amendment I would like to go back to
the um OS and as them to revise it based
upon the requirements or leas
recommendations coming from the
Department so we can comply with federal
law okay um representative Lon uh thank
you Mr chairman thank you for your work
on this representative Merchant um I
almost thought with the biological
products you should have added bio
similars um but as far as the attempt in
order to try and do this I I think that
it makes sense to try and figure out
what wording Works um I think we can
figure out whether or not it's going to
pass the whole committee at that point
but I think that trying to understand if
there is a way to do this without
absolutely opening up the barn door to
anything and everything would be
important so we can talk about this
specific
topic thank you m uh president Lon I
would ask the chair though before we go
through all that work and another
hearing next week it's just a straw poll
if people are willing to add the
RSV monoclonal antibody to the list if
the if there's no appetite here within
the committee it may be something we
have to to think about differently but
I'm just looking at the committee as a
whole if we have a straw poll of what
the uh committee thinks okay um okay per
representative Merchants request uh who
would support such an amendment or an
amend it to Amendment to the
RSV
Amendment given the fact I see enough
hands around the table if it's okay with
the share I will move forward and
represent L on if you want to work with
me on that Amendment i' be more than
glad to have you look at it with your
set of eyes as well I I'll look at it
the best I can with the bandwidth
available thank you all right so so if
I'm reading the room right we will
continue 559 also I so we thank you okay
so we will be so that'll be three bills
continuing okay um and there was a
motion right that needs to be withdrawn
at this point was yes and and I was the
second okay so you withdraw I assume
both motion and the uh second I
withdrawn all right moving on to the
final bill to be considered an executive
session this morning sp sp
560 uh representative Merchant would you
like
to been I mean you're on a rooll you
might as well I initially was thinking
of um making an amendment to the
bill having been on involved with the
prescriptions Dr affordability board and
recognizing the challenges with
transparency throughout the whole
pharmacy supply chain pvms are a major
piece of it but they're not the only
player but when you start looking at you
know manufacturers the role they have
wholesalers um
Insurance parties themselves are you
offering a motion yes I'm just I'm going
to make a motion to OTP on the original
Bill and not introduce an amendment
second representative L on seconds and
then please continue your remarks I just
wanted to get a motion out on the Mr
chair so I think the bill when you look
at what's going on in the pharmacy
supply chain
the 800lb gorilla is really the pbms and
how they use the formulary how they use
different parts to it um to influence
how either what drugs prescribed what
the pricing model is going to be there's
rebates that go behind the scenes
there's a lot of activity within the PBM
world World itself that is really not
transparent and I think the goal here is
to allow for a legislative committee to
begin to a understand what is going on
behind the close The Wizard of Oz and at
that point in time based upon the
information they can ascertain is there
a legislation we can introduce to try to
bring greater transparency to the
marketplace at the same time ultimately
bring drugs becoming more affordable to
the patients so I'm in totally support
of the underlying bill as in introduced
to us by the Senate with no additional
amendments representative land did you
wish to speak to you a second uh yes
thank you Mr chairman thank you
representative Merchant for part being
part of the group to bring this forward
uh many many years ago when I was
working as an analyst on Wall Street
when my senior analyst left my company I
was given the opportunity to cover pbms
back in their infancy um it's a very
complex and interesting area but I was
worried about some of I was worried
about some of the incentives and how
they align and I didn't really feel
comfortable pushing that to investors in
order to grow that market so I stayed
with implantable devices um I've been
following this field and there's
definitely benefits from pbms but
there's also a matter of just making
sure that as you look to it um that
everybody says equally balanced so this
push and pull between manufacturers and
pbms and payers and prescribers and
patients um continue continues to be a
good Fair um balance of U priorities and
needs um I think that this is very
important because this is complex and um
it has a significant impact on the
overall cost of healthcare and this is
one that does have um an impact on
Medicaid on private insurers on
everybody and it has an impact on what
drugs and drugs we actually get brought
to Market because you need to make sure
that a drug will be profitable when you
bring it to Market when you spend over a
billion dollars getting it approved so I
think that this is very important um and
I'd be happy to be one of the
Representatives on there um I know that
a lot of times I like to know who's
willing to volunteer to serve before it
passes and hopefully representative
Merchant maybe representative
Oakford thank you represent other
discussion representative Murphy thank
you and I would only add that I would be
in support of the OTP for this bill
Alone um and I don't disagree that the
pbms are complex in their nature they
very much are it was very apparent
myself working with representative
Merchant on the uh prescription drug
affordability board that they were the
single most complex but also the least
transparent among the people involved in
the pharmaceutical chain so it would be
nice to have a committee to look at all
of the the people that have a hand in
the distribution of pharmaceuticals but
the gun but the problem but the to me
the one that is most uh or the least
transparent the most complex is the pbms
and so I think this would be a good
starting point that we could um all
discussion seeing I'm seeing none okay
okay um with that I'll ask the clerk to
call a rooll a motion is out to pass on
Senate Bill 560 representative Lon yes
representative kushman yes
clerk votes yes representative kofalt
yes representative mlan
yes representative Seth King yes
representative Missour
yes representative bogert
yes representative pelosof yes
representative Weber yes representative
McKay yes representative fedus yes
representative Canon yes
representative Nutter upam
yes representative Shapiro
yes representative Merchant yes
representative Murphy yes representative
Palmer
yes representative
tez represent McDonald yes 20 to zero
motion passes there is no objection uh
consent okay all right that concludes
our executive session business for this
morning uh we will be in recess until
1:00 p.m. until at which time we will
hear testimony on Senate Bill 461 again
then
e
good afternoon everyone and welcome back
to the house committee on Health and
Human Services and elderly Affairs we
have four uh bills to be considered from
the Senate this afternoon in public
hearing first one is SB
461 Prime sponsor is Senator Rosenwald
and she's already in position welcome
Senator and GL to see you again thank
you nice to see you Mr chairman members
of the committee um I find myself in an
awkward position bringing you this bill
as introduc used in the Senate it simply
repealed RSA 329 colon
49 everything else besides the effective
date in the version before you today was
added without a public hearing and
therefore had no input from the public
providers or me so I bring you this bill
as amended by the Senate with language
that I am opposed
to and I want to be clear I am not
opposed to data collection and Reporting
as long as it has strong very strong
privacy
protections those of you who know me
know that I am really interested in
privacy and I believe that privacy is
particularly important for for medical
information this bill as amended by the
Senate does not include privacy
protections for patients it does not
prohibit but allows for the identities
of women who receive abortions in New
Hampshire to be potentially released to
the Department of Health and Human
Services and as you know
that would not be a hippo
violation because the department is a
hippoc covered
entity strong privacy protections would
require that all protected health
information be removed before mandatory
reporting leaves the
provider and is shared with
HHS this bill now leaves the door open
to letting our state government know
specifically who is getting an abortion
in New Hampshire for me this is
completely unacceptable it violates New
Hampshire values and I think it violates
our state Constitution's privacy Clause
as well Granite Staters do not want
government intrusion into their private
information and this includes the
identity of women who obtain abortions
in New
Hampshire the bill also does not de
identify the health care providers who
perform abortions leaving our doctors at
risk of intimidation and threats to
their safety we have a hard enough time
attract ing doctors to New Hampshire and
with labor and delivery units closing
around the state I don't think we should
be making our state a less attractive
place to practice
medicine finally this bill gives more
work to
DHHS without the financial resources to
do it I have spoken with the department
they project they would need one and a
half positions and a secure data system
to comply because the department can't
just keep this data on an Excel
spreadsheet the um total cost for the
coming fiscal year from what they said
to me would be over a million dollars of
General
funds Mr chairman I don't believe we can
ever go wrong with
Shakespeare so let me just close by
quoting Mark Anthony and Julia
Caesar I come to bury Caesar not to
praise
him this bill for me is an unacceptable
violation of medical privacy thank you
Mr chairman I'm happy to answer
questions thank you Senator
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair thank you senator for your
testimony um we've heard from you what
you don't like about the bill but it was
originally drafted by you and right what
what what what did the bill originally
do what was your intent of the bill to
to begin with the intent of the bill
originally was simply to repeal 329
429 which says this is part of the fetal
Life protection act and that sentence
which my original Bill repealed said
nothing in this subdivision shall be
construed as creating or recognizing a
right to abortion this version before
you maintains that repeal but adds to it
what I consider to be a really
unacceptable violation of both the
patients privacy and also the
physician's privacy followup follow up
thank you um now you mentioned that it
didn't have any public hearing I'm
assuming it went to the Senate's H HHS
committee and and it didn't have a
public hearing or what can you explain
that a little bit more in detail it went
to the Senate Judiciary Committee it had
a hearing on the underlying
bill this amendment
which gerus is in the eyes of the sen
president was brought into committee
adopted in committee and voted on the
floor but did not have any input from
anyone outside of the committee okay
thank
you other other
questions seeing none Senator thank you
also signed up to speak is Patricia
Tilly from the New Hampshire Department
Services good afternoon chair members of
the committee thank you for the record
my name is Patricia Tilly I am an
associate commissioner at the Department
of Health and Human Services I have
worked in maternal health for many years
and I've had the opportunity to review
many bills with similar goals as Senate
Bill 461 I will be providing technical
information on the bill the department
is not taking a position at this time so
thank you for accommodating me and
letting me speak early on this bill I
know that there are many folks who want
to weigh in as described by Senator
Rosenwald and other Senate Bill 461
redefines RSA
32949 within the fetal Life protection
act New Hampshire is one of only a hand
full of states that does not man mandate
routine collection of information around
abortion there have been several
unsuccessful efforts in the past to
legislate data reporting systems but
because of the privacy concerns stated
by Senator Rosenwald technical questions
and the financial implications the
general court has not yet authorized
such collection for Speed I will divide
my testimony into our observations about
the data and just an acknowledgement of
the costs but before I get there we know
that New Hampshire in New Hampshire
privacy is Paramount in everything we do
former representative Kirk is behind me
and others are going to remind you again
of that Duty as drafted Senate Bill 461
seeks to limit sharing personally
identifiable information however it does
require some elements as you heard from
the senator um and then in some other
areas that uh bring into question and
would require to have a HIPPA compliant
data system in order to secure and
protect that privacy in particular it
requires date of in place of an abortion
performed per Hippa date of a procedure
is protected health information this
means we need to be sure that any data
collection is secure and in compliance
with HIPPA standards so starting on uh
line eight of page one we see a full
list of proposed data elements I talked
a little bit about date we also need to
address the word place there is no
definition in the current bill of place
so this could be an address it could be
a broader geographical location like a
county or it could be a facility type
like a hospital including a specific
name I would encourage the committee to
consider what it is they mean by the
word
place um we would and in order for the
Department to enact this we would
clearly need we would need clear
legislative intent moving to line 12 the
department recommends that the cons
committee consider changing gestational
age when the abortion was performed to
be redefined to estimated gestational
age this would be in better alignment
with clinical recommendations and quite
frankly this is where rul making
Authority similar that is granted to
other New Hampshire statutes where we
that require Health Data reporting it
would be helpful so because of the
sensitivity of the proposed data
elements the department would need to
collect the information through a secure
data repository this is not the kind of
private sensitive health information
that you want delivered you know on the
back of a napkin or on a slip of a piece
of paper or an Excel spreadsheet or sent
to an ancient fax machine especially
when we consider that there will be
numbers of these rep reports coming in
we want to do this if if required we
need to do it
appropriately so that means the
department would need to develop a new
hipa compliant electronic mechanism for
healthcare providers to report data no
such system uh currently exist or could
be repurposed for this activity so this
is where we get to cost there's a range
of costs as we all know to implement any
system there are no funds available at
the department at this time or or
currently scheduled to be budgeted in
the next panium budget adding to the
operational cost would be the need for a
full-time um coordinator to un to uh
look at the data report uh coordinate
and Report the data um and an addition
part-time Prov um it's System Manager
administrator to maintain system
operations onboarding facilities
maintaining user access these are all
standard things we have for our other
data reporting systems in the state line
19 highlights that the bill is effective
upon passage but because of the
technical requirements that I have
detailed and financial considerations um
an effective date of on Passage would
really be impossible we do not have a
mechanism today to collect the data the
committee at the end of the day is going
to balance the importance of this
Private health information and the cost
of collection
we ask that you're in your Calculus you
take care in defining data elements and
ensure that adequate resources are
available to support the development of
necessary systems and ongoing operations
to secure privacy thank you thank you
representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman and thanks
you miss Tilly for taking this question
I know in the past when similar um bills
have been brought to to this committee
there they were brought with the
intention of reporting um this
information
to um the federal government to the CDC
is that is that the intention of this
bill as far as you know or do you not
know I I can't see where it says sure so
thank you very much for that question
representative um so I don't know the
intention of the bill um we were not
consulted around the intention of the
bill I can tell you that the data
elements that are listed in this
particular Bill are far fewer than what
CDC recommends um so we would have to
figure that out moving forward of if CDC
would even be interested in this level
of data because the CDC actually
recommends a much broader set of of
information and I I just to be clear the
CDC does not require this information it
is on a voluntary basis just to be
clear other questions representative
kosman thank you Mr chairman and thank
you Miss Tilly for being here um would
the department be more comfortable if
these records were sent to um the
division for Vital Statistics since they
do um similar data upkeep regarding the
birth
worksheet thank you for that for that
question so in the past we have had
bills that have looked at abortion
statistics in which the data went
directly to Vital Statistics the
relationship that the Department of
Health and Human Services has with the
Secretary of State's office is they
collect um they collect the data but we
are responsible for the health data for
any analysis on that data so we would
get the information through them they
would you know in the scenario that
you're discussing as in previous bills
they would incur the cost of the data
collection system we would then incur
the cost of the analysis thank you other
questions representative Merchant thank
you Mr chair and thank you Mr taking the
question I do have a concern about line
nine age of pregnant Pat age of the
pregnant patient and also in regards to
a
location if we are too specific
indirectly we could identify the
individual because we could link the age
Pi a small community
to um a patient and I think I do have a
grave concern about that being in there
particular if you narrow down the
location or the place of the abortion is
relatively
narrow thank you was there a question
question qu sorry my question is what
can we do to prevent the issue of the
the location what do you recommend sorry
for
the question thank you I think the the
committee needs to consider um both
privacy and also the accuracy of the
data or what it is the intent of the
data would be I can tell you that in
other data sets when we have information
um that has some of this protected
health information in it for other
health
um areas uh we don't release when there
are small numbers in a small area so
again with your description we would not
release you know potentially under five
events in a in a town that information
then is reported to us it is not
publicly
released follow up thank you for that so
in this bill the way it's written where
would that prevent the re release of the
the information we're talking about so
this is um thank you for the question
thank you for the followup um this is
where something like administrative
rules are helpful because we could
detail that level of what will be uh
publicly presented and what will not be
publicly presented you could put it in
Statue you could put something about uh
I think the committee needs to consider
what the definition of place is
primarily and then um determine if age
is an important item for you to collect
and then you could put in additional
language either in the statute or give
us the um rul making Authority where we
disclosed if I could follow go back to
rule making so do we have
to it's more of a procedural question
maybe to the chair somebody else do we
need to include ruem Authority in here
so the department has rule making
Authority because without that I'm not
sure they have broad up Ru making
authority to accomplish what we're
asking them to
accomplish good question that I don't
know I mean Miss Tilly would you know
yeah typically in statutes like this
there is a granting of rulle making
Weber as an initial matter Mr chairman
um I note that I am one of the sponsors
of the original Bill uh and it's my
understanding that I am allowed either
to ask questions or to speak to the bill
but not both is that correct that's my
understanding Okay so uh and you've
called on me so I will go ahead and ask
the questions um if if you know uh in
your interactions with Vital
Statistics uh is this the kind of
statistic they currently correla and do
they
have
um
systems that are currently Geared for
this kind of statistic as opposed to the
ones that they currently colle they
currently do not collect this kind of
statistic this would be new information
for them and you know I don't want to
speak for the Secretary of State's
office or Vital Records but there would
be providers um feasibly who would need
to report that typically don't report
into Vital Statistics
now followup it's actually a different
question sure go
ahead so um did you give us a sort of
estimate or any kind of a range of what
such a system if if you were doing it in
DHHS is this bill requires um the the of
of the cost for a system for you short
so as you know there's no fiscal note
attached to this bill so we did not
provide one um we think that there's a
range of costs I would prefer to um have
the committee go through some of these
data elements and consider and then we
could probably come back to you with a
more refined number we will need a
system and we will need someone to run
that system is really I think the place
where you can start okay I believe
Senator rosenal mentioned a million
dollars
is in in a conversation that we had
previously that was my off the head um
uh estimation but again we would want to
know more exactly about the data
elements that you're interested in
collecting and then we can give you a
more precise number okay but do you
think that's well you know roughly
accurate it's in a ballpark okay thank
you other questions
you this for this
year I announce if you can um I sent
it okay uh Miss Dyer our researcher just
informed me that she got the amended
fiscal note on the bill and and at the
present time there's no fiscal impact
expected um how that might change in
time remains to be seen but um is am I
accurately yeah okay um okay so um
moving on uh next uh signed up to speak
is former representative Neil
Kirk you've asked for three minutes
representative Kirk I did Mr chairman
thank you and good afternoon to you and
to members of the committee for the
record I'm Neil Kirk uh I live in the
town of we and today I'm representing
myself
um this bill requires medical providers
to report abortion related data to the
Department of Health and Human Services
and I support that concept however the
bill is drafted in such a way that it
impinges upon privacy rights and I would
ask the committee to amend the bill or
study the bill to protect these privacy
rights with respect to the patients
privacy rights the bill allows a
patients personally identifiable health
department section
32949 bans requiring the transmission of
personally identifiable information to
the department but it doesn't
prevent a medical facility from
providing it in other words the
department can't require the medical
facility to give it that kind of
information but nothing prevents the
medical facility from naming names if
it's so wished this could be prevented
and patient privacy rights protected by
adding after as requiring in that
section the words or permitting this is
especially important considering the
recent privacy amendment to our state's
Constitution which states an
individual's right to live free from
governmental intrusion into private or
personal information is natural
essential and
inherent the Department of Health and
Human Services our state has has no
legitimate interest in learning the
names of women who have had
abortions the patient's privacy rights
are also at risk if she should get an
abortion in a physician's home office
and this was alluded to in one of the
questions uh prior to my testimony yes
even today with doctors uh being
Consolidated in hospital practices there
are some doctors who do maintain offices
in their local community how are the
patients privacy rights at risk here
current law defines medical facility to
include a doctor's office so a woman in
a small town gets an abortion at her
hometown doctor's office and her doctor
because his office is a medical
facility would be uh have to be listed
as providing one abortion and in a small
town it may be very obvious to folks as
to whom that woman was to preclude this
I would ask the committee to amend the
bill to ban the department from
providing its statistical data by named
medical facility or type of medical
facility medical privacy rights also are
an issue here while the bill does not
require a medical facility to report to
the state either the name or number of
abortions an individual employee
performs nothing precludes it from doing
so the committee should amend the bill
to ban that information from being sent
to Health and Human
Services I would also ask the committee
to amend the bill to exempt this data
from the state's right to no law
as we're all aware abortion related data
is very sensitive for both the patient
and the medical provider and it should
not be available to any person outside
those charged by law with collecting it
safeguarding it and creating statistical
reports finally as was mentioned in
prior testimony I would ask the court
the committee to consider that there are
cost to this bill a secure data system
data entry and data analysis isn't free
the department is probably in the best
position position to provide a cost
estimate but an appropriation to the
department by this committee even a
dollar would be very much in
order um one last point that I'd like to
make before concluding um there was some
discussion before about Vital Records
please recognize that Vital Records is
not covered by Hippa any information
that's sent to them does not have to
meet hippo privacy
requirements that's different if the
information goes to Health and Human
Services as this bill requires so if you
amend the mill Bill to allow the data to
go to Vital Records you are really
exposing this data to no private privacy
protections thank you Mr chairman I'd be
pleased to answer any questions from
committee members thank you um and
earlier when I said there was no fiscal
impact that was a different bill that we
had received information on so I
apologize for the confusion um the
original ballpark estimate of a million
do is apparently is is correct uh
questions for representative Kirk
representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman and welcome
home to your very own committee room to
the very own committee room
um I was wondering you you had a place
where uh a statute which I think is not
this one needed to be changed to um as
requiring or permitting and I was
wondering if you could give give me the
the site to that statute again please um
it is this statute it's the first
section on the bill oh so it is in the
bill I'm sorry it's on
line um line four nothing in paragraph
two of this section shall be construed
as requiring and then add the words or
permitting the communication of dis or
disclosure of personally identifiable
health information could I just ask one
followup that um do you have an opinion
as to whether it's stronger to say
nothing in this statute shall be
construed as requiring or committing or
simply saying requiring or permitting is
forbidden which seems to me to be a more
direct construction considering your
legal background uh I would I would uh
opinion the point is it needs to be
corrected and there are different ways
to do it thank
you other questions
representative kushman thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here Mr
Kirk good to see you um I am wondering
you said something that um caught my
interest because now I'm concerned about
the birth worksheet that goes to the um
Department of Vital Statistics um it's
not protected by Hippa and there's a lot
of very sensitive information in that do
you think that it would be more
appropriate for it to go directly to the
Department of Health and Human
Services to be protected probably yes
but that's a controversial issue so uh
tread carefully before you move in that
direction okay thank you other
questions seeing none thank you thank
chairman also signed up to speak is
good afternoon uh you've asked for three
minutes good afternoon chairman McDonald
and other honorable members of the
committee uh for the record my name is
Devon chaffy and I'm here to testify
today in opposition of sb4 61 thank you
for the opportunity to do so um this is
not the first time that I have been
before this committee to testify on an
abortion data collection bill in fact
the New Hampshire legislature and this
uh and the New Hampshire house in
particular has considered data
collection bills very similar to what is
before you in s SP 461 many many many
times in both recent years as well as
many times over the last decade that
I've been working at the New Hampshire
legislature and every time the house has
considered such legislation it has come
to the same conclusion and it has
rejected the bill and so that really
begs the question of why why has there
been such consistent opposition to these
types of bills for so many years and I
think the answer is simple and quite
frankly uh um has been made clear from
the testimony prior to mine which is
there are serious privacy concerns that
stem from this type of data transfer and
collection there are serious concerns
that you heard detailed um by DG J by
the sponsor of these this bill as well
as um from uh representative Kirk uh
about the personal prate Healthcare
information that could be put in
Jeopardy by this type of data collection
scheme the bottom line is we all know
that breaches in of personal health
information happen and that they happen
in New Hampshire we have seen breaches
by the New Hampshire Department of
Health and Human Services despite their
best efforts to keep information private
such breaches have compromised Social
Security numbers addresses and Medicaid
identifi identification numbers and such
breaches inevitably create risk that
some Granite Staters personal medical
decisions will be
disclosed we all know that the risk of
uh that healthc care data can be uh
reidentified it's a real risk and yet S
sp4 61 doesn't do anything to allocate
funding to ensure the security of this
information I also want to make a point
that hasn't yet been made which is that
the
risks currently in recent years of the
consequences of breaches of personal
abortion data have gotten far more
significant as more and more States
criminalize abortion
procedures so in short the stakes have
gotten a lot higher when it comes to
abortion data and how they can be used
by States outside of the State of New
Hampshire after the do's decision there
have been significant reporting of
harmful uses of healthcare data to
Target those who seek abortion Act
access there have been uh instances of a
data broker broker selling the location
data of people who visited abortion
clinics there have been cell phone and
social media app data being used in
abortion related
prosecutions and right now we have at
least 33 states that have criminalized
abortion laws and 16 states that have
made it a felony to perform abortions
some states have even threatened
providers with lifetime sentences for
violating these bans and at least two
states in at least two states the
Attorneys General have threatened
prosecution on conspiracy charges for
doctors who refer patients out of state
patients traveling out of state
themselves as well as organizations that
assist pregnant people and accessing
care in states where abortion is legal
so in other words you start wrapping up
please yes sir in other words what we
see is that in states where abortion has
been criminalized they are using their
laws to reach outside of their state
borders into states where abortion is
still legal like the St State of New
Hampshire and they are using data to try
to go after individuals who are engag in
conduct Beyond uh their State's borders
the bottom line is that Granite Staters
care about privacy and their personal
information as representative Kirk noted
that's why over 80% voted in favor of
codifying in our state constitution an
individual's right to live free from
governmental intrusion and private or
personal information and for these
reasons I urge you to recommend SB 461
in expedient to legislate thank you so
much thank you uh representative Seth
King and then representative Merchant
thank you Mr chair and thank you for
taking the question I actually called on
Seth King oh sorry that's okay sorry
thank you Mr chair uh and thank you for
your testimony it's been said earlier
that there's nothing in this bill that
explicitly requires a provider to give
the name name or other personally
identifiable information to the
department but you'll have to excuse me
I don't have the current RSA that would
be repealed and reenacted in front of me
is there any is there any current
protection in law that um so for example
there was the concern that with a
legislation like this even though
there's nothing that requires them to do
that a provider might actually still be
able to voluntarily relinquish that
information is there anything in current
law that prevents them from doing that
now thank you representative uh King for
your question I I don't know of anything
and I I'm not I'm going to admit I am
not a hipa expert but I am not aware of
anything in current law that would
prevent them from doing so I also
believe that the concern is that there
are so so there is so much specific
sensitive information that is being
requested that that that that
information could potentially be
reidentified even if the name wasn't
included thank you thank you
representative representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair and also
thank you representative King for
bearing with me in regards to the issue
raised about the state of residence I do
understand the concern what are you your
thoughts about having it either a
resident of New Hampshire or not a
resident of New Hampshire so therefore
it's not identifying per se of the state
but whether it's internal or external to
the state thank you representative I
mean I would I would have to look at any
proposed amended l language to to fully
try to understand what the implications
might be um I mean I think you've hit on
a very important point the fact that
it's actually identifying States makes
this particularly concerning given what
is happening in other states and the way
that they are criminally targeting them
um I you know there is still even if you
take out the um the state there is still
additional very specific information
that is requested in the bill as
currently drafted so I think that fix
alone would not solve the issues um but
certainly if there was Amendment
language we would be willing to review
it representative Weber thank you Mr
chairman and and to follow up on uh
representative meron's
observations it would you agree that to
Simply identify as instate or out of
state would solve a great deal of the
privacy
issues uh because or or at least those
that arise out of somebody who might
have traveled from a state uh where
where the laws are different but if you
then simply say in state or out of state
the data isn't very helpful in terms of
data because there's no way of
determining who has traveled great
distances to come for this or who as
many people those of us who live in
Border towns uh get some of their
Healthcare on one side of the river and
some of the Healthcare on the other side
of the river a lot of people in in
eastern Vermont uh come to Dartmouth
health for for their medical treatment
as As a matter of utter
routine uh so would data gathered in
that matter manner be useful for any
kind of policy analysis well I
representative thank you so much for
your question and I think that is one
that the committee needs to seriously
consider we've heard testimony including
by DHHS about the serious privacy
concerns with the way this bill is
written and with this type of uh uh uh
data collection system but what is
unclear is why are we trying to get this
data so if we're going to create the
system that creates serious privacy
risks to Granite Staters what is the
benefit to it and what I am hearing is
that this is not information that CDC is
requesting that they wouldn't request it
in this way and it is far far from clear
as to what this um what this data in the
specifically in the way that it's being
requested here would even be used for
and I think those are very important
elements for the committee to consider
followup and as a
followup would you agree with me that
looking at all or or most of these data
issues that they fall into the same
quandry where for data collection
purposes
and for policy analys you know for for
creating having adequate data to create
good policy we need the most specific
data possible but that is what provides
the most risk to privacy to
reidentification to misuse and so the
more protections we put for privacy
sake the less useful the data is in
terms of policy and analysis yes I
representative thank you so much for um
for putting it in that way and I think
you know I would even go a step further
and and really think who who do we need
this data for policy purposes why are we
singling out this medical procedure for
data collection and I think the answer
from that um is not has not been made
clear thank you other
questions I'm saying no other questions
also signed up to speak is Sandra denan
Center good afternoon you asked for
three minutes I did thank you very much
thank you to the committee for accepting
my testimony today I do have written
testimony that I'm passing around um but
for the record my name is Sandra denor
I'm the executive director at the
lovering health center in Greenland New
Hampshire uh we are an independent
nonprofit Health Center with over 43
years of experience providing abortion
care in New Hampshire we're one of the
reproductive Healthcare facilities
directly impacted by you move the
microphone closer to you please of
course so we are one of the healthcare
facili is directly impacted by Senate
Bill
461 I want to note that the lovering
health center voluntarily reports
abortion data to two national
organizations the gut marer Institute
and the National Abortion
Federation we are opposed however to
Senate Bill 461 for important
reasons Senate Bill 461 requires
reporting abortion data with no clear
intent to positively impact public
health so when we consider as a Health
Center and a facility the risks that
data sharing could pose to our patients
and to our facility and to our providers
if we had a clear indication of what the
public health impact of that data could
be we would be collaboratively hopefully
collaboratively designing a system to
achieve that purpose that's not what
happened in this proposed amendment that
sits in front of you today I appreciate
that your questions indicate you're
willing to critically consider what this
amendment can contains uh but there
still is no clear discussion about what
the public health impact the positive
public health impact would
be so we have shared historically a
commitment with DHHS and bipartisan
legislators um to improving Public
Health but most notably as partners in
the title 10 Family Planning program the
defunding of Family Planning contracts
for the Levering and contracts for all
New Hampshire abortion providers over
the last three years sends a very clear
message
it signals that this is not the time
when we can expect abortion data or more
detailed abortion data to have any
impact on rebuilding the successful
Family Planning Network that achieved
the lowest teenage unintended pregnancy
rate in the country and a Family
Planning Network across the state that
would naturally and effectively impact
and reduce abortion rates abortion does
not exist outside and separate from
other public health initiatives it's not
an other in the healthcare Spectrum if
abortion data was essential to New
Hampshire's Current public health
initiatives it could already be obtained
from public sources obtaining abortion
data using Senate Bill 461 as amended is
a want not a need and I see it as an
opportunistic intentional overreach with
potential harmful
impacts Senate Bill 461 has no funding
attached to create secure adequately
managed and maintain reporting systems
it's unreasonable to ask providers and
Facilities to report data without
adequate cyber security and data
management capacity Senate Bill 461
allows for significant subjectivity in
the interpretation of vital language
which folks before me have testified to
and I have heard you consider
thoughtfully thank you for that but
absent details about specific elements
required and addressing the concerns
that have already been presented to you
today we cannot support Senate Bill
461 this bill also requires reporting a
patient's state of residence with no
Shield law place to protect providers or
patients in New Hampshire in this post
row National landscape and considering
the current New Hampshire landscape the
timing and the structure of Senate Bill
461 pose a threat to both providers and
patients you could start wrapping up
please yes the data that's being
requested is being requested at the same
time that multiple States as we've heard
with abortion bands are just beginning
to exercise their right to pursue and or
prosecute leg uh providers and patients
who obtain abortion care with legal
Protections in New Hampshire the legisl
the legislators who proposed this bill
cannot safely say there is no path to
identifying patients and or pursuing
providers and this risk is unacceptable
thank
Weber thank you very much for your
testimony and thank you for taking my
question I I wanted to just ask a quick
followup uh about the statement about uh
the public health aspects of um having
any impact on rebuilding the successful
Family Planning Network that achieved
the lowest teenage unintended pregnancy
rate in the country since the defunding
of Planned Parenthood in the centers has
our place in in the national rankings
changed unfortunately I'll have to defer
that question to the Department of
Health and Human Services who would have
that data yeah thank
you other questions representative
Merchant
thank you Mr chair thank for taking the
question I'm looking at the first
paragraph and in that first paragraph
the third line it
says lovering voluntarily reports
abortion data to two national
organizations GM Institute in the
National Abortion Federation can you
share with us what those data elements
are that being
reported
absolutely so the reported elements that
we submit are aggregated into Statewide
data which is an important component of
why we report to these two uh
organizations is because it is it is not
reported publicly as facility specific
data it is aggregated into Statewide
data so there's benefit and there's
certainly privacy protection in that
process we report the number so the
volume of abortions that we provide and
we also report the method as defined by
either procedural or completely managed
with
medications and that is what we provide
followup thank you Mr
chair would then would you be opposed to
that data also going to the state
database if we're just basically sending
it to two national organizations could
we therefore send that kind of data to
the state so the state would have that
I feel that the state can access that
data if they want aggregate data it's
available it's available at the GOP
marker Institute website today so you
can see what the estimated volume of
abortions provided in the state of New
Hampshire are today um and I would say
that without the secure systems that we
would expect and confirmation of what
the public reporting would look like and
that it would be aggregated not
identified by facility those would be
important elements for us to ensure part
of the legislation if it's proposed post
now the followup thank you Mr
chair in regards to the data going to
these two organizations and its
aggregated and you talked about the fact
that in the state of New Hampshire are
you talking about multiple locations in
New Hampshire sending data to the gut
marker Institute versus doing it
individually TR trying to follow what
your folks are doing and if that's the
case is it mandatory or is it voluntary
because part of the data in here in the
bills it shall be done versus it may be
be done yes so it is voluntary data
reporting is voluntary at this point
although um I believe if you wanted to
verify with the G mocker Institute how
they if they believe their data is
comprehensive and reflective of activity
in the state of New Hampshire the answer
yes and the second part of your question
um I have concerns
about which I didn't mention in my
testimony but I do have concerns about
the enforcement of the word shall so I'm
concerned about how you validate the
data I Supply you or any facility
supplies to the Department of Health and
Human Services with an unfunded
unstaffed um mandate is how do you
validate that data without accessing
Private health information and so if the
data that we are supplying
voluntarily is considered inadequate in
some way I would ask how do you ensure
this legisl that the data we're
supplying is adequate to you and that's
a fundamental concern that I
have representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here um
I looked at the gut marcker Institute
and all I saw was a bar graph where it
was on a 5,000 scale so trying to have
an understanding of what the actual data
are in New Hampshire was essentially
impossible um I don't know if that's
available more granularly and you said
that it is a vol voluntary is this all
of the abortions that are happening in
New Hampshire or just those which are
chosen to be re
reported uh because it's voluntary it's
those that are chosen to be reported
however uh our understanding and my
understanding is that it's fairly
accurately reflection of what's
happening in the state of New Hampshire
there is a state specific map uh through
the GP marker Institute that is
available um uh that does become more
granular so I would encourage you to
Simply explore that website perhaps some
more detail but there is an abortion map
that covers not only the state of the
legislation in the state but also the
volume of abortions provided in more
detail follow um thank you um so as I
clicked into the state and I went to the
data on New Hampshire it was a bar graph
measured on the 5,000 granularity
perhaps there's something else but if so
it's pretty hard to find in there my
other question is um do you uh take all
the information within the state and
then send it to G marer or do each of
the individual providers their
information individual providers send
you also signed up to speak is Kaya mon
you've asked for two
minutes yes good afternoon members of
the committee my name is Kayla
Montgomery I'm the vice president of
public affairs for Planned Parent of
Northern New England and Planned Parent
of New Hampshire action fund um we have
testified on background on this bill for
a number of years in front of this
committee and we continue to express
that we are fine with the collection of
abortion statistics if done securely and
for the purposes of legitimate EP
epidemiologic iCal purposes as we can
all agree that good data equals better
Public Health outcomes now PPN and our
four Health Centers here in New
Hampshire we are nonprofit healthc care
providers who follow all state and
federal laws and if this bill were to
pass we would most certainly comply um
but we do have a few concerns so many
things have already been addressed so I
will try and keep this brief um there
was already a robust discussion around
um how concerns around how this
information could be used in postr World
um so I will just say that that's also a
concern for us well New Hampshire
doesn't have any shield laws in place
and we I think we can all agree that
nobody would want any of this
information weaponized or used um
against the state of New Hampshire or
against any patients who are coming to
our
state um we talked a little bit about
gutmacher Institute uh we at Planned
Parenthood Northern New England we also
provide information and uh data to The
gutmacher Institute um this is linked in
my um testimony um anyone can go online
and look at that information uh they
collect aggregate data so there's no
risk to patients or providers and we
have been working with them for decades
uh we have full trust in how they're
using their data and that it is being
used for good Public Health outcomes so
that is certainly something we will
continue we will continue to work with
them um and uh continue to provide
information to them um one that hasn't
been discussed yet is uh the section
that says uh any prescriptions written
for the purpose of inducing abortion um
this is a a place that would great it
would be good to see a little bit of
clarity uh in this line because I
believe the intent of that line is to
determine whether an abortion is
medication or procedure um and if that's
the case it should probably just say
that because as it is written it's a
little bit confusing of what would be
required of us to
report um prescription medication is
really specific to the individual so
it's unclear if we would have to list
say the names or the doses or the
quantity for each patient and that type
of data collection is really more about
individualized medical care and it's not
a vital statistic so that's one area um
that needs some clarity and uh DHHS
already talked about this but I just um
I also o want to reiterate it because uh
I think it's probably the most pressing
thing for Planned Parenthood at the
moment is that this bill doesn't address
the method of how this data is collected
so we see in lots of other states there
is a secure online portal for instance
in Maine you know that is a PPN an e
State we go in and we enter the data
through our secure online portal but
it's not specified here uh if we would
have to fill this out daily um where do
we do it do we fax the form do we mail
it do we walk it over to the
Commissioner's Office uh it's not
specified and it it also isn't specified
the Cadence of the collection it says at
least annually or as reported by the
commissioner you could start wrapping up
please sure so that could mean daily and
the reason that this is really pressing
is because there is an immediate um date
on this bill so we would have to figure
out those Logistics right away um so in
closing if um the legislature decides uh
a formal collection of abortion data in
New Hampshire for clear and specific
Public Health purposes they should
present a detailed method of secure
collection and we certainly understand
the concept of this bill but with roie
Wade overturned and the reproductive
healthc care landscape and complete
chaos in this country the New Hampshire
legislature should take every precaution
to protect abortion providers and
patients privacy in the granite state
thank you thank you representative Seth
King thank you Mr chair thank you for
your testimony um you briefly mentioned
Maine and it sounded like you spoke of
it in a positive light uh the
information you give in Maine uh you
seem fairly happy with can you tell me
what
information is required to be given in
Maine and and juxtapose that with what
is being asked to be required in this
bill is there anything in this bill that
is required but is not in main or vice
versa sure so the state of Main and I
I'm using main as example because it's a
state that I work in and so I'm
comfortable with it but um Maine has
like a state specific CDC um which is a
part which is a division of their Public
Health um so it's an entire you know
hippoc compliant website that's already
in existence and the information that
they ask um they actually used to ask a
lot more specific information they used
to ask about education and about race of
the patient they have since um taken
that away um but it is uh it is a system
that is in place that there's a lot of
confidence with abortion providers that
the information is secure follow up
follow up do you know or recall if they
asked for the date and place of the
abortions performed in the age of the
pregnant
patient I don't I don't know but you
could go online U truly it's very easy
to Google and just look at it thank you
other
questions saying none thank you thank
you
also signed up to speak is Elena Cass
Health sorry that's my handwriting I'm
represented from Dartmouth H oh I'm
sorry that's okay that's my handw w okay
well no there's no there's no line down
on the on the on the D so I should a d
if that's the worst thing I do
today so uh thank you chair was Courtney
Tanner also I'm sorry for the record
Courtney Tanner her name was in
parenthesis so I wasn't sure if she was
there okay I'm not going to say much um
uh for the record Courtney Tanner senior
director of government relations at
Dartmouth Health with me today I have Dr
Alana Cass who's our department chair
for um our
OBGYN department and um Dr Gretchen
Stewart both practicing providers and I
figured their committee would have a lot
more questions for them than they would
for
me good afternoon to the committee thank
you for giving us the opportunity to
testify
my name is Dr Gretchen SAR Stewart I am
a board certified obstetrician
gynecologist I'm also an attending
physician at Dartmouth Hitchcock Medical
Center in Lebanon and a professor at the
geil school of medicine at Dartmouth and
as part of my clinical practice I take
care of patients who require abortions
and I am here today to ask the committee
to oppose Senate Bill 461 Senate Bill
461 is risky for patients with no
benefits Senate Bill 461 proposes such
detailed data collection that an
individual patient could be traced to an
individual clinic or procedure these
details include the patient's age the
date and collection of the procedure the
state of residence of the patient
gestational age of the patient and any
prescriptions written for the purpose of
inducing an abortion as a scientist and
a researcher I love data but for every
data Point collected there should be a
justification the justification should
explain the reason for each data point
and the contribution that that data
point will make to an individual or
Society Senate Bill 461 puts patient
privacy at risk yet the benefits of this
data collection are not stated in the
bill in fact in the proposed Senate Bill
461 there are no benefits to patients or
to the people of New Hampshire the risk
RK of data breach intentionally or
unintentionally puts at Great potential
harm those who have contributed the data
to this data set as I spent time
understanding this bill some questions
came to mind what are the benefits of
mandating this data
collection who will benefit from this
data what are the benefits of sharing
this private data with the general court
of the State of New
Hampshire overall there are often
unintended consequences of data
collection we all have seen examples of
that the collection of individual
patient data related to their abortion
is risky to patients and I urge you to
you
sorry so my name is Dr Elana Cass I'm
the chair of the Department of obstetric
Gynecology at Dartmouth Hitchcock health
and I'm here to Echo the sentiments of
my colleague and many of the individuals
who've spoken today uh urging you to
please uh consider s SP 461 as an
amendment without a real clear purpose
that exposes patients to unnecessary
risk for unclear benefit that I think
poses a burden upon healthc care
providers again with no understanding of
why and finally uh does expose my
providers and other providers in the
state of New Hampshire to significant
Peril in light of many of the points
that the speakers ahead of me have
suggested uh with regards to the uh
current uh sort of State the current uh
map of uh of access to abortion care uh
which could have significant Downstream
consequences to our ability to have
adequate providers in the state of New
Hampshire to care for granite
Staters I am happy to take any questions
but can assure the uh group today that
this would this data collected in its
current uh iteration I think there is
very significant risk posed even with
the consideration as suggested by some
of removing the state uh is an
individual in state or out of state I
think there is still significant uh
Peril given the uh inevitable uh you
know artificial intelligence and or
ability to uh kind of collocate data I
think all of us have experienced this
when we've innocently done a Google
search on a particular trip to a
particular place and then suddenly we
are targeted thereafter with cookies and
the like and without any provision for
who is collecting this data what are the
safeguards in place to really lock that
down uh and again with no clear benefit
in mind I think this exposes my
providers at risk I think this exposes
patients to risk and I think It
ultimately exposes the people of the
Granite State to risk this is a slippery
slope and I would urge that we strike
down uh Senate Bill
461 thank you representative
Shapero thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking the question could you
give an example of the type of perel
that might be
um that might occur to uh a provider an
abortion provider um in New Hampshire if
as a result of this kind of data
collection and data reporting absolutely
so let me give a a the first example
which at this point would be absent The
Shield law that you've heard many people
allude to if one of our providers in the
state of New Hampshire were to
administer services to a patient who
comes from a state where that uh
provision of care is illegal in some
scenarios that provider if that could
actually be traced to the provider which
I would submit to the group is feasible
very much feasible in the context of the
current uh uh Bill Amendment um that
provider could potentially be subject to
legal action uh revoking their license
um Jail uh at in the state of origin uh
where that patient came from more
proximally however I would submit to you
that there are uh certainly individuals
who who would use this information if it
could be traced to a specific provider
to um Target that provider to Target the
place where that abortion was provided
uh placing both patients other patients
who come to seek care from that facility
as well as the provider in Peril and
then again it's not a far-fetched uh
conclusion that they could figure out
where my provider lives or a provider
who who offered these services and they
could find that person at home with
their families so all of this is
feasible and there is precedent for
every scenario I've just
outlined
followup thank you um when these kind of
bills have come up in the past I've been
contacted by a
constituent whose uncle was a physician
abortion provider I think in Buffalo or
around Buffalo who was shot and killed
so are you also concerned about violence
um affect ing yourself or providers in
your practice I'm absolutely concerned
about that I mean I don't need to remind
you of the terrible episode we had uh
with a with an Irate family member who
came and and shot one of our providers
at Dartmouth some years ago admittedly
different circumstances but all of this
has happened before um every single
month we read about you know some irate
individual who shows up on the doorstep
of a medical center provoked by whatever
reason I think this just gives another
piece of Amun
to those individuals and places our
healthare system both patients and
providers in
questions seeing none representa for the
record I will be submitting um written
testimony from one of our other
providers Dr Amy Paris who's the
director of Family Planning and OBGYN
research so that will come around okay
all also signed up to speak is Jason
sir am I on now y awesome thank you Mr
chair uh for the record my name is Jason
Hennessy I president of New Hampshire
right to life I also have some
experience that might be pertinent to
this I played a leadership role as part
of a national epidemiology study and one
of my responsibilities was overseeing
the compliance of the medical data that
we collected with Federal privacy rules
I as a researcher I also published novel
research and privacy in uh
internationally peer-reviewed
forms one thing I want to just point out
is that according to G marcker which is
a uh pro-abortion research group 46
States and the wa and the and Washington
requirements so right now the fact is
that the only people who have this data
are the private providers themselves
they release it when it meets their
interests and don't release it when it
doesn't and you can you can understand
why in a competitive industry you would
want to keep that data
private but I I I submit to you that the
legislature and the public needs this
data so for instance how do we know how
safe abortion is in New Hampshire I've
seen on a lot of promotional materials
that abortion is safe inlegal New
Hampshire how do we know we have no data
the people who have the data they
they're not going to share it if it's if
it doesn't meet their interests there's
been a lot of uh there's been a lot of
students around the fetal Life
protection act over the last couple of
years in terms of how many late term
abortions have happened how many haven't
we don't have any data because there's
no data
collection uh so the qu so the question
is uh do we already do this and the
answer is we already collect a lot of
personal data I'll draw your attention
to the New Hampshire Comprehensive
Health Care information system chis
a version of which is publicly available
to anybody and this includes procedure
date times provider places of I think
most uh health insurance transactions
for New Hampshire health insurance
providers there's also the adverse
reporting adverse event reporting form
which also includes time and dates and
the hospital
location um I also want to draw your
attention to the 2022 study from the CDC
uh the abortion surveillance this is a
national study that comes out every few
years and New Hampshire is called out 22
times because we don't provide any
data we're we're called out in the in
terms of the limitations right at the
beginning
So and I've heard a couple of times
where people ask the question why do we
need this well the CDC report has
several reasons uh I'll just give you a
couple evaluating programs aimed at
promoting Equitable access to patient-
centered contraceptive care in the
United States to reduce unintended
pregnancies assess changes in clinical
practice patterns over time in
information in this report on the number
of abortions performed through different
methods and at different gestational
ages provides a denominator data that
are necessary for analyses on the
relative safety of abortion
procedures now we've also heard some
conversation about the cost and who
should be doing this with DHHS or Vital
Statistics um I'll just point out that
as I was reviewing the uh the laws in
our neighboring states main Vermont and
Massachusetts Vermont calls it a fetal
death report and they include this
uh I believe as part of their of their
equivalent of our Vital
Statistics so um also I've heard some
concerns about
privacy uh one thing I'd call your
attention to is that there is not one
example of harm that's happened in any
of the 46 States or DC over the decades
that this data has been collected that
can be tied back to start wrapping up
please okay thank you Mr chairman uh in
conclusion I I just want to also State
we do request a couple of changes uh
first one would be to keep the field
Life protection in intact uh we have
we've heard no testimony that this has
caused this language has caused any harm
uh we would include the reporting of
post-abortion
complications include a penalty so that
it's enforceable for instance Vermont
assesses a $500 uh VI ticket for
violation uh give give some Ru making
authority to whichever Department you
decide and in terms of
confidentiality uh has uh has a very
short law it includes confidentiality
requirements and with that I would be
happy to take any questions thank you Mr
chair thank you representative Seth King
thank you Mr chair thank you for your
testimony um sounds like there are 46
States um many of which are very
favorable for um pro-abortion Advocates
that take some sort of data um and I'm
just curious
when you look at the list here A through
f is are all of these things in all
these other states or does this bit of
legislation go above and beyond what is
asked in these other states or I mean it
sounds like you're hoping that we'll at
least catch up to where everybody else
is because we're so far behind does this
go too far is there any is there
anything in this list that you would be
find getting rid of to you know maybe
catch up with where Vermont or Maine or
Mass chusetts are for example would you
be fine with getting rid of A and B and
then keeping C through F uh what are
your thoughts on this uh thank you
representative I I unfortunately made
the Cardinal mistake of not bringing up
a copy of the law U but what I will say
is that as I reviewed the other states
for instance I've got the main law right
in front of me it has date in place
abortion was performed the age of the
person on whom the abortion was
performed um I believe most of these
concerns these data points that other
people are concerned about have been
talked about
follow up follow up these other states
like Vermont and
Massachusetts why do they even have this
here I mean it sounds like generally
speaking people that are pro abortion
don't like this information being there
and yet in states that are very Pro
abortion they have this information did
this information get slipped in under a
a very short Republican regime or what
happened why why is it that these states
even have this information uh if if they
generally don't like it thank you
representative uh I cannot speak to the
intent legislative intent for why they
have it but I can I can call your
attention back to that 2022 uh CDC
report where they outlined several
reasons why they think at a national
level uh this is very important for
health outcomes thank you representative
mlan thank you Mr chair and thank you
for taking my question um so we heard
prior
testimony that the data that is being
asked for in this bill is just a
completely incomplete data set and the
fact the CDC is not going to be very
useful to them so I'm trying to square
your testimony saying this is data that
the CDC wants versus other testimony
that is saying this is a completely
incomplete data set so I'm wondering if
you kind of you know round out that
Circle for me how did this data how was
this select Ed um and how does it
compare with these other states because
it seems to me actually we would want to
be taken away with adding and I'm just
I'm just trying to square the circle so
thank you representative uh so if you
look at the CDC report there's actually
a lot of data that they would like to
collect that is not in here but as I
mentioned we're called New Hampshire is
called out 22 times because of data we
don't collect so it'll be something like
oh here here's the uh abortions by uh
gestation limit and says New Hampshire
doesn't report this uh you know if we
can get that down I mean more data is
better than less data and other states
collect a heck of a lot more data than
this um but this this is a very good
start follow
up uh thank you Mr shared thanks for
taking the follow-up question which is
not really a follow-up but um
representative Kirk talked a lot about
the Constitutional Amendment we have
which I totally supported and I continue
to support and so he was raising a lot
of the privacy concerns that I share but
he also went through a lot of fixes that
he would put in place to kind of address
those concerns um are you supportive of
those um or what are your thoughts on
that thank you representative uh my
opinion it would be that collecting
something is better than collecting
nothing and so if that's what if if if
that's what the committee would be
comfortable with uh we would be in
support of that representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair
and I concur with represent McLean New
Hampshire has in its
DNA privacy um so much so that we have
it in our own state constitution and I
really get nervous when we start having
in the state to collect data in any way
that resembles personal data it could be
a even if you try to De identify it
number two what question I have to you
is that would you be okay with I think
we do it many times is the opt out let
the patient opt out of it if they don't
want their information collected instead
of us mandating it that the patient
always reserves that right to protect
their privacy and therefore they can opt
out of it thank thank you representative
uh one thing I'll call your attention to
is that uh most studies that I've seen
the way that they collect information is
that they collect even personal
personally identifiable data maybe at
the state level or if it's a private
group doing it a private group but then
they have strict rules on how they
release that data and so that and that's
where the that's where the agency rul
making comes into place because those
rules change over time you know it used
to be that you can include zip codes now
you know we decide you don't because if
there's too few people um go going back
to your so sorry said the question I
asked is what is your opinion of
supporting the right for a patient to
opt out of collecting any data that they
don't want collected because that's what
a constitution allows for oh thank thank
you for the
question I so I have not read every
State's uh abortion data collection law
I but from the few that I have I have
not seen anything about that I I'll also
say that um I really appreciated the
Vermont way of doing it which is they
consider it fetal death and Fetal death
can be various reasons but the fact is
there's a there there is nobody can
argue that there is a human being who
passed away and so therefore there
should be some sort of record for it in
some
fashion other question representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman so there's
um there's been a lot of talk about the
intention behind this bill um some
people saying it's not clear what the
intention is other people talking about
a public health um reason um and you you
suggested something about not having
information
about the safety of abortions in New
Hampshire so my question to you is your
organization is your organization
invested in having safer abortions in
New Hampshire or is your organization
invested in further restricting
abortions in New
Hampshire so thank you for the question
representative we our my organization
seeks to protect all
life whether that's the mom or the
baby other questions
see no other questions thank you thank
you Mr
chair no one else has signed up to speak
on Senate Bill 461 does anyone
testify good afternoon Mr chair members
of the committee for the record my name
is Ava Hawks and I am the director of
advocacy for the New Hampshire Medical
Society uh as I noted on my pin card I
put three minutes but you've heard a
great deal of testimony majority of it
repeats my testimony so I'm just going
to summarize and reinforce some points
um for transparency and for clarity the
medical society supported Senate Bill
461 as introduced in the Senate we are
opposing the bill as amended by the
Senate um as you've already heard uh
thoroughly today in a postro world
providers of abortion care and patients
alike are immediately alarmed when they
see legislation that seeks to report
sensitive abortion care health
information including a pregnant patient
state of residence and the method used
to perform an abortion information that
we know has been weaponized in states
that are currently hostile to abortion
care and reproductive Health Care
Providers um I will reiterate that when
we present when presented the
opportunity this legislative session uh
the beautiful body across the street did
reject measures to implement a shield
law in our state and so to that point I
I want to reiterate the points raised by
previous testifiers that with that lack
of a shield law protection in New
Hampshire uh we have additional concerns
about codifying such reporting um in our
state and I will note just last week
Main's Governor signed a bill into law
to protect their State's providers of
abortion care from actions by other
states so a shield law and other states
in New England have done the same I know
there's been um a number of data sets
and reports referenced today and I know
there was mention of other states who
already collect this data I I am not an
expert on when those laws were
implemented throughout the 46 States in
DC but I would I would implore the
committee to maybe look at what what
times those laws were implemented and if
they were before uh the Dos decision so
I will leave it at that and I I'm happy
to take any
questions any
questions saying none thank you thank
you anyone else wish to testify on
sure thank you just since Mr henness he
brought up the comprehensive claims
database just want to clarify for the
committee that that database is
specifically prohibited from including
any personally identifiable data thank
you thank you okay with that um on the
blue sheet in the back two people signed
up one for one against and online
representative Layon and online oop
sorry I scrolled down from it online
there were eight in Support 32 opposed
and three neutral
thank you and with that I'm going to
close the public hearing on Senate Bill
461 and open the public hearing on
Senate Bill
412 Senator Rosen W you don't even have
to make a special trip you're already at
the table I'm already here you're the
sponsor of this bill so welcome back
thank you for the record Cindy rosenal
Senate District 13 I neglected to
introduce myself on the previous bill
but I have the honor to represent most
of nashwa and I really pleased to
introduce Senate Bill
412 which will allow Cedar Crest an
intermediate Care Facility serving
children with disabilities and complex
medical needs in Keen to temporarily add
two more beds for two
years as you may recall from last year's
House Bill
2 Cedar Crest came to us a year ago and
said there was a New Hampshire child
receiving care residing in a facility
out of state whose family would like the
child to come back to New Hampshire but
there was no better available at Cedar
Crest which was the facility that was
able to care for them so in House Bill 2
we authorized one additional bed for one
one year the reason that the state needs
to authorize additional beds in the
first place is that we've had a
moratorium on long-term care bed
expansion in place since
1995 we put the moratorium in place
right after we became the first state to
close our Institution for children with
develop mental
disabilities that was done in response
to
litigation since we closed the lonia
state school we have prided ourselves on
the fact that we partner with families
to provide the array of services that
allow children with complex
developmental disabilities to live in
their
communities the long-term care
moratorium is important for other
reasons too we've had a decades long
focus on rebalancing long-term care it's
what most individuals and families
want it's also less costly than a
nursing home and since the majority of
long-term care is paid for by Medicade
cost is an important
consideration and the long long-term
care moratorium is also important
because we have a Workforce shortage
that's particularly acute in health care
so I am fully supportive of allowing
this temporary expansion to help Cedar
Crest serve New Hampshire's children
with complex needs and so I believe that
two additional beds for two years is is
appropriate and I'm happy to answer
questions representative Lon um thank
you Mr chairman and thank you senator
for bringing this to us um looking at
this the only question I really see is
this doesn't take effect until June 30th
um does do they need to have this
flexibility sooner or is June 30 30th
soon enough
um well I think that that's a great
question I don't know at this point if
we could get it
enacted and signed into law before June
30th but if you wanted to make it
effective on passage the reason the
reason it says June 30th is that the one
extra bed expires on June 30th so if we
allowed two extra beds before that it
would actually be three extra beds for a
month so that might
be um
disruptive oh thank you I think that's
that's why I drafted it as June 30th
thank you and then as a followup looking
at that if somehow this ended up being
July 4 well it wouldn't be the fourth
but a few days later we should at least
have that intent that it's continuous so
I like your language thank you thank you
other questions representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question and for
bringing this
legislation um I have visited Cedar
Crest and my question
is the care that they provide is very
specialized and very comprehensive for
children who are both um very medically
needed and also
developmentally
delayed and my question
is why are we sunsetting the two
additional beds in
2026 do we know that specific children
will have aged out of the necessity or
aged out of eligibility for Cedar Crest
at that point um
or I I guess I'm wondering why we don't
just authorize the two additional beds
and leave them there because although I
don't have any idea of the statistics in
this particular population I am aware
that there are any number of types of
conditions that children have that
require us to send them out of state
because we don't have the available beds
to treat whatever it is that they need
whether it's mental health care whether
it's um abuse neglect followup whatever
it is H so my question is why are why
are we limiting it with the sunset and
are two beds adequate
well that is a long question sorry
for a future legislative session this
bill was a
negotiation um I guess I would say that
Cedar Crest also in addition to having
children with complex needs reside there
maybe permanently until they age out
also offer some
respit but it
also um houses some children from other
states my inclination is that we should
serve New Hampshire's children first and
so
I settled on this is what I'm willing to
do if you want something different
please find a different sponsor and I
know
they're you'll probably hear from them
but this was what I was willing to do I
am not willing to blow up the long-term
care moratorium I was not planning on
getting into this today but you brought
start just picking and choosing or
otherwise blowing up the long-term care
bed more
moratorium the next people asking for
expansions will be the
counties and I think the state cost of
uncontrollable and so I'm a cautious
person by
Nature you know I said on finance I
worry a lot about the Medicaid budget
this was what I was willing to bring in
thank you other go ahead I have
questions about that County statement
but I realize they're completely
irrelevant to this bill so we can have
that conversation offline representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman sorry
um I know you talked initially about
kind of the sensitive um relationship
between institutional care and home care
or Community Care and um so this is kind
of a would you believe question would
you believe that in my years serving on
the Ethics Committee at at Cedar Crest
that they um do everything within their
power in my view to promote family um
involvement family um sensitivity to
family needs and that they really go the
distance in terms of bridging that gap
between institutional care and um making
it personal and family centered I
certainly would believe that I guess I
should also mention that as you know
Crotched Mountain closed a few years ago
but it's been sold and um the new owner
is trying to reopen it that might be a
place where some children with complex
medical needs also could reside so I
just I'm too cautious to blow up the
long-term care
moratorium representative kushman sorry
about before that's okay thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question and you just um opened up to
what I was going to ask about is
Crotched Mountain because I re just last
week got um a request for help from an
86-year-old grandmother who is Raising
her medically complicated
grandson and
they he's in the day program at Crotched
Mountain but they do have residential
over there and she's trying to get him
in there so I did reach out to the
department to see what we can do um so I
I wasn't aware that it was my
understanding from looking at their
website that they do have their
residential program Open um so that's
why I was one my question was going to
be this doesn't specify Cedar Crest um
and so what might we end up with a uh
competition over who gets the bed and um
I just it seems that there needs to be
some long-term solution for this issue I
know you don't want to blow up the
moratorium but maybe we need to start
inching it um a little wider so we have
more beds available maybe on a slow um
slowly
opening scale what are you what are your
thoughts so um the reason it doesn't
mention Cedar Crest is that they're the
only
Intermediate Care Facility in the state
for
miners um Crotched
Mountain was licensed as a
hospital so um they're different I guess
my reaction would be we should serve New
I agree thank
you any other questions for Senator
bosen
you also signed up to speak and I'm not
sure if I'll pronounce the name
correctly Jay hastan I believe it is
appropriately from
cedarest you've asked for 10 minutes sir
if you could keep it under that I'm sure
thank you chairman thank you committee I
was anticipating questions in the time I
brief uh for the record I'm Jay haston
I'm a Swansea resident I the president
and CEO of the Cedar Crest Center for
children with disabilities and
Keen uh as you as you may know our job
is to provide exceptional complex care
and education to the state's most
medically and developmentally complex
children our job each day is to handle
incredibly challenging medical
Developmental and therapeutic needs so
that these kids can be kids uh so that
they can play that they can learn and
they can grow we're a private not
for-profit licensed as the state's only
Intermediate Care
Facility uh ranging in age today from
infants through age 22 we're the only
facility of our type in the state to
give you an idea of that medical
complexity 40% of the children we serve
right now use ventilators to assist with
their breathing for all are part of the
day and 100% of the folks that that we
serve currently have a g or a GJ tube by
which they get the majority of their
life- sustaining
nutrition if you are familiar with other
nursing homes in the state you know that
it's very rare to find a single
ventilator um in an entire Nursing Home
in our small facility we have 10 we also
provide special education instruction
and an approved private school on our
premises as well as a great deal of
respit care to give families and
caregivers a much needed break
by way of context last year we had seven
long-term Admissions and 62 different
respit
stays uh we feel that our role is very
critical in the Continuum of Care
because we're the only pediatric
post-acute setting with this population
specialty meaning we're the only place
for someone to go who has this need
profile to wean off of a ventilator uh
to to to get lung function strong enough
to go home with parents if if that is
the long-term goal we celebrate
discharges it it is uh Bittersweet when
someone you've known for a long time
goes home but it is our our favorite our
favorite thing to do uh when someone is
able to graduate from our setting to a
less restrictive
setting the average age at admission is
seven and the average length of stay
over a long period of time is
approximately 3 years that includes uh
folks who were with us for a very short
period of time as well as folks who are
with us over a period of years because
they may not have a home setting to go
back to um consider children who are in
DCF custody that that sort of
thing demand has increased for for our
level of of services so over the past
handful of years we've seen a marked
increase nearly a third uh in inquiries
for our level of care inquiries tend to
take a long time to mature from initial
Outreach to a referral to someone
spending time with us so even though we
have a high volume of inquiries you see
last year 110 inquiries a little more
than half of which would would be deemed
appropriate for some of our one or more
of our
services uh and seven long-term admits
and I think that speaks to the idea that
it is a long process to go from hospital
to home including potentially a stay at
Cedar
Crest we're very grateful that our bed
license was expanded by a single bed
last year in House Bill 2 uh we maintain
an active weight list of resp and long
stay inquiries um over the next couple
of months without uh the the current
bill or uh the the existing bed
extension we have 18 18 different respit
requests uh that would put us over
capacity and that's just over the next
couple of months of of of
Summer also want to mention that
families and children are in need of
these services for which we're the only
setting Hospital partners and Care teams
want to discharge these kids to a postc
environment it's important in that
Continuum of Care this frees up critical
beds and hospitals and saves taxpayers
money as the cost of Care at Cedar Crest
is between two and five times less per
bed day than what it would be in a
specialty hospital like
Dartmouth uh as we are the only facility
of our type families who cannot support
Care at home turn to us for a break for
a rehabilitative stay for day education
in our school or sometimes for a longer
term
stay given the sensitivity surrounding
the bed moratorium we worked with
Senator Rosenwald on on this proposal
for for two additional beds uh this is a
unique population and their needs are
well met in our setting as the only
setting for them in the Continuum of
Care we thank you for hearing this bill
and urge its passage as
introduced I'm very happy to take any
questions okay thank you rep
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman thank you for taking my
question um just a simple question I
would hope what is the total capacity of
C Chris right now sure so our base
capacity is 26 we have long been
licensed at 26 uh beds in the home um 27
given house bill to last year thank you
other questions representative
mlan yeah thank you and thank you for
taking my question so um so if you have
what is the average weight time then to
get into Cedar Crest and what happens
how what happens with these people while
they're waiting sure it's a great
question it depends on where uh where
that referral is originating uh majority
of our referrals come directly from from
the hospital so it might be an infant
who is PR presenting with these sorts of
complex needs and perhaps the family
need needs more time or or the child
needs that post-acute stay to get strong
enough to go home those referrals uh
tend to move more quickly because
they're uh as as you're aware is a a lot
of pressure to free up hospital beds
sometimes the conversations play over a
longer period of time if you think um I
believe rep rep kushman mentioned an
aging caregiver when it's an aging
caregiver situation ideally we're uh
having conversations well in advance of
uh of needing a stay and so we can work
with the team to uh to assemble the
supports to to to get folks to us we we
have not had to delay many admissions
over the past couple of years but part
of the conversation with the senator and
uh with our team around this legislation
was we're we're bumping up against it
where you know particularly spring and
summer where we're very busy with rest
bit stay requests we we have had to get
into that game of Tetris of we cannot
accommodate the rest bit stay that you'd
like for this week but we could do it
the following week you know so juggling
the needs of of families who who desire
a short-term stay against those longer
term admissions uh has become a
complicated exercise and we are
concerned that we are we we are bumping
up against that need to to delay
followup thank you Mr chair and just a
quick followup so this bill is for two
years so it's it's a temporary thing I'm
assuming it's a bridge to something um
so what happens at the end of this two
years what's what's what's the next step
um in terms of uh where we're going with
this sure great question so we we have
sort of the narrow question of of two
beds and then there sort of more general
question that the senator alluded to in
in terms of the bed moratorium our
physical plant capacity would not uh
comfortably accommodate more than 28 uh
long-term beds and so this uh positions
us well for for for where we are
currently we're in the midst of a
long-term analysis of both population
Health as well as our census Trends to
try and project uh what the need may be
over time we know that it has increased
sharply in the post-pandemic uh time
frame but we want to be very sure that
that we know how much it might increase
going forward so I think that this bill
is uh uh well well timed and well
positioned for us because it allows us
to utilize all available resources over
the next two years and to make the case
um if there is a community need for the
period
following other
questions representative
Weber I was just interested in drilling
down a little more on the balance
between
uh what I would call possibly
inaccurately long-term care versus the
respit care um do you have a sense and I
understand your point about the game of
Tetris you know you I already have
people in this bed do you have kind of a
an average balance between the two of
those who are in in long-term residents
versus those who are short-term yeah
it's a it's it's a great question and
definitionally
uh any stay greater than 30 days is
considered a longterm stay for us and so
at any given time we may have a handful
of folks that that earn a long-term stay
but it has a clear a clear end point
it's 60 days for rehabilitation
postoperatively or it's 30 days while a
caregiver is is rehabilitating from a a
procedure um or uh needs to travel uh
currently we have 23 long-term stays so
folks who are in that uh 30 days or more
category and two short-term stays um I
may have mentioned earlier over the next
couple of months our short-term stay
requests pick up uh pretty significantly
we try to reserve a couple of um spots
at all times for those rest bits stays
uh yeah I hope that answers your
question thank you representative Murphy
and then representative Merchant
representative thank you once again um
just a question with um um CIS
particularly are you normally at 100%
capacity and if so how do you staff that
and with whom do you staff the um the
the support that you need there yeah
thank thank you for the question uh we
over the past three years that I've been
affiliated with the organization we have
been close uh to to fully uh fully
occupied uh we have been fully occupied
on a handful of different occasions
um so I mentioned right right now today
we're at 25 uh we have multiple requests
over the next couple of weeks that would
put us above capacity I think our
average
utilization um over the time that I've
been with the organization is somewhere
around
24 uh perhaps 24 and a half but uh so we
we have buted up against it um to you
know to belabor that Tetris analogy it
it it does uh uh stack awkwardly
sometimes where you have three folks who
need a short-term stay as you have 23
long-term admits and now we're up
against it for a period of weeks in
terms of Staffing we we are we are very
very lucky um in that uh employees are
strongly attracted to our mission uh and
have been uh with us for a long period
of time and tend to come to us uh we we
have experienced challenges with
Staffing as uh as all skilled settings
have uh of of late but relatively
speaking we we have weathered it um we
we have weathered it we have uh
proportionally fewer openings than than
other skilled other skilled settings do
right now um I sit on the board of the
Healthcare Association uh for for New
Hampshire and when I talk with my
colleagues in long-term care uh they you
know
they're 10 and 20% higher Staffing
vacancies than than what we experience
at cedarest so while we can always use
more staff staff is not uh not where it
was previously we have been relatively
lucky follow thank you Mr chairman U
Staffing that many beds is really
remarkable um in hospitals that becomes
dangerous uh do you have uh but more
specifically do you are in that group of
people that are Staffing the the
facility are there Travelers involved
with this or these are all local people
yeah great question so we right now
today I have two two Travelers
in the building on on Time limited
contracts uh We've made it a point of
Pride to to limit the use of Travelers
given the medical complexity of the
population you know there's a learning
curve anytime you uh you use Travelers
but doubly so uh in in our population um
so we have 90 regularly conditioned
staff another 50 or so per Dum staff and
and we've been really lucky to to have a
very engaged prum staff pool and and to
be able to for much of last year we did
not use any Travelers uh we have a brief
overlap where we have two in in house
right now one will conclude their term
in a couple
weeks representative
Merchant thank you Mr chair the question
I had was asked by representative Murphy
so thank you oh okay thank you any other
questions seeing done thank you yes
thank you appreciate it uh
representative Shapero could you give me
does anyone else wish to testify on
FN signed up in the back uh in support
of this bill was Brendan Williams from
uh Penbrook and online online there were
two in favor zero opposed
okay with that I'm going to close the
public hearing on Senate Bill 412 FN and
open the public hearing on Senate Bill
554 FN uh recognize the prime sponsor
Senator Jim Gray uh Senator welcome uh
we do need a oh you've got your pink
card okay way ahead of me you know the
drill looking for the opportunity to
hopefully if you hopefully if you will
allow we'll be able to get you back on
track at least a little bit this bill is
pretty simple our hearings are very
unpredictable my name is James Gray I am
Senator representing Senate District 6
which starts up in Alton and gton comes
down Route 11 to
Rochester right now we have uh two
departments Health and Human Services in
the office of uh Prof professional
lenser which goes out and checks records
for we don't need them both to do that
uh for these
certifications uh one is good enough and
if you pass the Bill uh that's what'll
happen they'll be able to cooperate with
each other and share the data and the
department is here to answer any
questions that I
can't think that's it any questions for
Senator
gray representative n Ram
you said um thank you sorry and thank
you for taking my question
certifications or a
lure well it all has to do with checking
their certifications to provide their
licenses okay thank
you any other questions for Senator gray
representative Murphy thank you Mr
chairman just a quick question so you're
saying that you're going to go from two
to one and that no difference in the in
the data shared would be different then
that's basically share data right now
okay and that's why what you see in the
bill in both the upper section and the
lower section and that's on line four
and on line 11 they both say
notwithstanding of the laws okay and
that's to get around the Privacy stuff
that we have uh built into other systems
so that you can't have one Department
share data with another department
unless you have legislation that allows
it to happen this is the legislation
that allows it to happen Qui follow so
for myself to be clear then what you're
saying is that you by virtue of this
bill are eliminating a position having
one position and therefore the data
that's shared is probably not
eliminating any position but we're
making it take less time for the process
to happen again the department will be
able to talk to this I mean you know
they can tell you how many people that
they're are licensed you know between
them and
oplc um I don't see that this doing that
but um you know when you go in for your
recertification how many times do they
need to check to make sure your license
is current and you know everything is
good we only need to do it once we just
need to be able to tell each other that
it's good perect thank you other
questions representative TZ thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for taking my
question
I I I would greatly appreciate if you
could sort of concretize so thinking as
an example Medicaid providers are for
example a hospital or the individual
Physicians the department will be able
to answer that much better than I okay
okay well then we'll wait thank you
other
questions seeing none thank you thank
you
also signed up to speak is Franchesca
Hennessy from the Department of Health
and Human Services good afternoon my
name is Franchesca Hennessy I am from
the Department of Health and Human
Services I'm the administrator of fraud
waste and abuse so one of the units that
falls under um me is provider enrollment
and I'm really anxious to answer all of
your questions I was just really ready
to get at it in the audience there so I
think um what I do want to emphasize
earlier someone um was asking about who
has authority to have this data oplc has
authority to have this data and DHHS has
authority to have this data so we each
have the data all this would be doing is
matching it in the data
universe so
um providers medical providers and and
you had asked representative who are
Medicaid providers that's hospitals
that's doctors Physicians Mental Health
Providers we have over 30,000 Medicaid
providers so it's all of them and
they're all licensed and Federal Law
requires us to have licensed providers
we can't have people who have dings on
their licenses and what happens is a
provider will enroll with Medicaid um
and then after five years they will
recertify their enrollment but in the
interim um for example I'm a lawyer and
I get re-ed every year so I in the
interim providers May expire and have to
show that they are relicensed
again and so those are the that is the
data Manch we would be constantly
sharing again in the data Universe these
licenses so oplc can show us so and so
is properly licensed and their license
is up to date and then we can also um
certify that to the federal government
say we are only paying Medicaid
providers who are properly licensed and
again those that
information is already possessed by the
department the provider willingly signed
up with with us and disclosed all this
information all we're doing is saying is
that information on your license or up
to
date that's it okay thank you any
questions from Mrs
Hennessy yes representative Murphy thank
you Mr chairman and thank you for taking
the question my question is if I as a
provider where would I go then who do I
go to to get certified um every other
year whenever that might be and how
would that mechanism work so your
license a providers licensed or
certified whatever the administrative
rules require of you um for example
you're a physician and you get licensed
every couple of years you go to oplc
they will they do their licensure there
and for for Medicaid purposes you come
and enroll with Medicaid and you show us
I'm properly licensed with
oplc so bottom line is that it will not
change for the provider oh no and if I
may go so far as to say this may make
providers happier because they don't
have to constantly be doing this work
themselves they can focus on their
patience and not proving to DHHS that
they're still properly
questions saying none thank what
represented Weber sorry I'm just trying
to figure out how you're doing it now if
DHHS is not allowed to communicate with
oplc how do you very ver ify now we or
our contractor conduent will go to the
oplc website and com through their
records so we take that um there are
times that it is missed and their
records are just out there and on
revalidation again that happens every
five years with the provider we may say
uhoh you need we need a current lure now
but really under federal law we should
have had that current lure documented
for the the past few years when we did
it so it protects us for documentation
purposes for the federal government it
also would save us a tremendous amount
of time okay or contct really yeah thank
questions I think I'm safe this time
representative okay uh no one else uh
that card is that for this one the next
one okay could you bring the blue shade
up too while you're
AC while he's up you know since he's
anyway okay one signed up on the blue
shade in the back in support and online
representative Lon online if I remove
the two duplicate entries it would be 15
neutral okay thank you uh does anyone
else wish to testify on 554
FM seeing no one I am to close the
public hearing on that bill 554 FN and
open the public hearing on Senate Bill
411 FN and recognize the prime sponsor
Senator Becky Whitley welcome Senator
thank you Mr chair good afternoon
members of the committee for the record
my name is Becky Whitley and I'm honored
to represent New Hampshire Senate
District 15 which you all sit in it
includes the wonderful communities of
conquered bow and hackington today I'm
honored to introduce Senate Bill 411
which takes just a minor step forward in
addressing New Hampshire's Children's
Mental Health crisis despite significant
public investment from the legislature
to ensure that children have access to
timely mental health treatment it
remains important to ensure that all
children including those with private
insurance have access to the care that
they so desperately need you may all
know that we saw significant increases
in children's mental health challenges
throughout the pandemic and we have not
seen that
dissipate in mid December right before I
introduced this bill into the Senate 18
children were boarded in emergency
departments in acute psychiatric crisis
waiting for care even one child awaiting
services in an ER shows that there is
way more that we can be doing 18 is
simply
unacceptable the system we have set up
to support Medicaid eligible children is
quite robust yet now we're seeing an
increasing amount of children with
private insurance in the Medicaid
system for a whole host of reasons and
this bill as originally introduced was
to address those gaps and hopefully
reduce the financial pressure on the
Medicaid system just to illustrate the
pressure we're seeing on the Medicaid
system it's worth noting that intake and
determination data from The Fast Forward
program that's the Medicaid Program for
children with significant mental health
needs so intake take between January
2020 and October 2023 showed that 20% of
those children referred to fast forward
were privately insured of those 20%
another
80% ultimately found eligible for hipi
Medicaid what we used to call Katie
needs so I will say that you know
children who are being pushed into the
Medicaid system there are a whole host
of reasons there's not just one reason
but it's something that we need to
really look at and really address the
total expense to the state for covering
Services render rendered to otherwise
privately insured children exceeded $2
million in the last banum that's both in
fast forward and within our community
mental health centers that are serving
children so this is just screaming out
for a policy solution the bill as
introduced um is was very similar
actually to a bill that was introduced
in the Senate three years ago by Senator
Tom Sherman making sure that there was
just essentially parity between what's
covered in the Medicaid system and what
private insurance carriers are covering
so that resulted in a whole host of
conversations between all the parties um
but it didn't resolve the issue so
that's why we refiled the bill this year
and again folks have come back to the
table and I just want to thank everyone
who's come back to the table to address
this issue and they really have um the
vast majority of carriers have been at
the table the Department of Insurance
the providers they have spent hours
working on this issue but we are not
quite there yet the Department of
Insurance who I believe is here today
also issued a bulletin based on their
initial work with all the parties but we
but many folks in the Senate felt that
it was important to retain legislative
oversight we don't want to have to come
back and two more years to file a bill
so that's why you will see the version
before you was amended to create study
committee to retain that legislative
oversight over this problem that we know
is occurring and again very thankful for
the Department of Insurance to the
carriers to the providers but this
provides the necessary legislative
oversight to keep everyone at the table
and keep things moving I'm happy to take
any questions I will surely defer more
technical questions to the folks behind
me but I ask uh for your committee for
the committee support of s
sp411 thank you representative Shapiro
thank you Mr chairman and thank you for
taking this question so when I first
read the um title of this bill I was
wondering why this exists since I was
just appointed to a commission on
Behavioral Health crisis Services um
shared by Senator Apprentice so it
seemed like the same thing but when I
read the bill um in fact this bill says
emergency mental health and this
commission is on Behavioral Health
crisis services
um a misnomer in some sense since this
is really this is this bill is really
addressing
um it might be it might be short-term
but it might also be long-term mental
health needs among children and mainly
focused on like what resources available
through what insurance sources yeah so
if few things I think the term emergency
was held over from a prior version of
the bill I think this this committee is
different because we're specifically
looking at children and we're
specifically looking at private
insurance coverage so it is a little
different than the other committee and
you know there are different
requirements in the children's system or
different needs for children so it was
necessary to have this committee look at
this discret issue um the other piece is
you know the goal of the whole bill was
to make sure that children with private
insurance had access to the same types
of services that children in the
Medicaid system have we're just at a
place where this legislature has in a
bipartisan way really built up the
Medicaid system to start uh working
through the problem of kids being stuck
in ER boarding room we are not there yet
I mean we are still in the in our ncy in
building that system but eventually
we're going to see you know those
residential treatments come down those
acute psychiatric hospitalizations come
down as more kids have access to these
services and we're just making Mak sure
that all children have coverage
regardless of their where their
insurance comes from follow up follow up
so I know from my time quite a while ago
working in a mental health center um it
was very there's a great irony in the
fact that more middle class families
with private insurance um those private
insurances didn't fund the same kind of
services that children with Medicaid had
like home visitors and people to take
them out into family workers to take
them out into the Community to um give
them socialization case managers so um I
know this has been an issue for a long
time and so that's really that's really
one of the questions that this um
attempts to address yeah yes absolutely
in particular what you mentioned
functional Support Services these are a
lot of the services that our community
mental health centers provide that keep
children and adults also but keep
children out of hospitals right so we're
looking through that and the fast
forward program so the fast forward
program is a is a Medicaid design
program now we achieved coverage for
this program in the Medicaid uh by doing
a state plan Amendment so it is a
combination you'll hear it described as
Home and Community Based Services which
in part it is but there is one straight
Medicaid service in there and that's uh
wraparound Services that's a straight
Medicaid service it is uh provided in
the context of the Fast Forward system
but if that makes sense you know it is
in some way ways it's Unique to um the
Medicaid system but in other ways it's a
typical straight service High Fidelity
wraparound I will also say there's been
a whole lot of work in the state to
figure out what High Fidelity wraparound
means and um I know uh representative is
shaking her head she's been at the at
the table for this since day one but it
is a evidence-based intervention to wrap
around the family you know provide the
supports that are necessary to keep them
out of a hospital keep them out of
residential placements which are less
effective for them and way more
expensive so we have to figure out a way
to get all kids access to services that
will keep them out of the hospital and
out of acute psychiatric
hospitalization followup one more
followup thank you um is it not true um
also that from like a Community Mental
Health Center's point of
view it's not really legal or at least
ethical to provide one set of services
to people with one kind of insurance but
not provide it to other people with who
didn't have the same kind of insurance
so that puts me Community Mental Health
Centers sometimes in the bind of um
either legally having to or feeling like
they should provide the same kind of
services even though there's no um
reimbursement through these private
insurances and they are you know I'll
let folks behind me speak about it but
they are providing those Services um
that's sort of part of the $2 million
that I mentioned that there are private
insurance uh there are kids who have
private insurance that are being served
by the fast forward with State dollars
and same thing with the Community Mental
Health Center I think it's just sort of
budgeted because we know that these kids
are there thank you representative
Weber thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
for taking my question just for clarity
um we were provided with a memo I think
all of us who sit on this committee are
well aware that there have been a
proliferation of study committees over
the last few years
to address what it we all perceive as a
very real problem uh am I right in
thinking
that the
difference is that this particular study
period
study um
is
um
directed much more narrowly to a
specific po population in a specific
issue than have um the broad committees
in the past yeah we we were quite
explicit in the duties for that very
reason I mean we're really trying to get
wrap our heads around this um both to
make sure kids get what they need and
also to you know start reduce you know
address the high budget we have in the
children's Behavioral Health uh Ledger
on with Medicaid so yeah we are quite
detailed and this is a quite specific um
set of Duties that the committee will be
looking at thank you and just one
followup followup um and and as you were
giving your your testimony you referred
at least once to um the need for
legislative oversight and I wonder as I
read this it appears to be more of a
study than ongoing oversight so I was
looking through there's no it it ends
with the end of this legislature so it's
a it's a one
time with an end and so what yes that's
correct what I meant by legislative
oversight is that there folks are
already meeting and it is important that
we just sort of keep them at the table
and have a me ISM to keep them at the
table thank you very much for that
clarification it makes me feel much more
like I understand what's going on yeah
representative
McCay thank you Mr
chairman I
Senator I'm a little bit confused about
the scope of this committee it says to
study emergency mental health services
so on
and under the duties it talks about
health laws insurance coverage claims
data lack of coverage which I'm not sure
what that means whether that's insurance
coverage and parity
compliance I don't see anything in here
about uh Sur the actual Services
provided for children so it's confusing
to me that that are we really talking
about essentially Assurance coverage or
is this
a committee that's looking at the
serious problem of lack of services for
those children thank you for that
question I think it sort of gets to
representative Shapiro's question the
name of the study committee is sort of a
hold over from the prior version of the
bill but really what we are looking at
is you know do children in who have
private insurance have access to the
same bre and type of services that
children in the Medicaid system have
it's really that discreet issue just
making sure we have parody there and I
think in some cases with some carriers
we do some carriers we do not right I
think as always there's many different
players at the table here but we need to
make sure that every child I believe
should have access to services so they
don't have to wait in in e in the ER so
it it really is focused on those uh you
know that discrete issue of
coverage other
questions representative Weber and just
following up on your answer to uh
representative McKay
um wouldn't it be true if we actually
were able to be a little more uh
understanding and proactive in the
insurance coverage or the payment side
of things we might actually achieve
greater servic availability because we
would have um a more stable way of
funding it that's
correct
yes other
questions seeing none thank you Senator
thank
you also signed up to speak is Emma
you put down six minutes is that because
there two of
you yes um and I'm going to be reading
testimony briefly uh from some of our
Advocates who are unable to be here
today um good morning or actually good
afternoon representatives and members of
the committee thank you for hearing my
testimony today for the record my name
is Emma savenia I'm joined with my
colleague Michelle Merritt
um we are from new Futures we are the uh
a nonprofit nonpartisan organization
that solves Pro solves problems through
policy change um in doing so we support
a full spectrum of services provided by
the robust system of care in New
Hampshire today we are here in strong
support of Senate Bill
411 um as you just heard so eloquently
by Senator Whitley Senate Bill 411 is a
continuation of a multi-year effort from
stakeholders um bipartisan
legislators um the department of of
Health and Human ins services and uh
insurance carriers to um come up with
the solution for um the lack of coverage
for certain services in the children's
Behavioral Health space and additionally
ensure that those cover that those
services that are hopefully now going to
be covered um continue to be covered and
continue to be available to the entirety
of the gred state children
population um as you also so eloquently
heard from Senate Senator Whitley this
is a um Senate Bill 411 was an attempt
to finish the work um that was done
around Senate Bill 70 back in
2022 um it additionally improved
definitions around Behavioral Health
crisis services and a a Litany of other
services it's been um amended to become
a study committee after the Department
of Insurance issued a bulletin um that
solved some of the issues that were
raised in the original version of the
bill um but uh fast forward and those
non-clinical um intensive care
coordination Services still remain
non-covered by many private insurance
carriers um those services are offered
to any child in New Hampshire um and
when insurance does not cover them their
private insurance does not cover them or
those children do not rise to the level
of Acuity that would give them coverage
under the state's
hccsd U Medicaid Program
um the state Bureau for children's
Behavioral Health covers the cost of
those Services um and so what the study
committee is tasked with um which is
different than what the previous study
committees that are outlined in the um
memo that you received uh what this
committee is tasked with is the very
narrow
um task of of reviewing the coverage for
those children who are impacted by uh s
severe mental health disorders um and
need this type of uh coverage for
services um when these services are
covered more clinicians more providers
are able to offer services at a
community- based level and that one
offers better outcomes for children and
two reduces the burden for those higher
level of services such as fast forward
or High Fidelity wraparound and reduces
the burden on our emergency rooms so in
in theory would reduce the emergency
room board in crisis which was initially
way back in 2022 the the reason Senate
Bill 70 was
brought um and so that is the most
important reason for this study
committee to help address the need for
services in our communities um need for
um our state to be able to have those
dollars that are currently going towards
um payment for services that should be
otherwise covered by private insurance
can then be reallocated similarly into
Community BAS Based
Services um to that end I'm now going to
uh just read some brief testimony from
um some of our Advocates who are unable
to be here but who have been impacted by
this situation um so this is from one of
our Advocates Tim roor uh he says Dear
members of the committee I write to you
today on behalf of my daughter and the
countless other children and families
navigating mental health issues in solid
support of Senate Bill 411 Senate Bill
411 requires not uh commercial insurers
to cover several community and
hospital-based services for children
experiencing a mental health emergency
while these services are available
through state funded programs such as
fast forward they remain difficult to
attain with long wait lists and limited
availability to meet the growing demand
expanding these types of services should
not be the sole responsibility of the
state and my daughter's case we are a
family with private insurance however
because of the lack of coverage for some
Services by private by commercial payers
providers lack the financial resources
necessary to expand access this means
that for children like my daughter
recommended services are not quickly
accessible leading to an inevitable and
preventable degradation in her condition
which now requires more intensive and
expensive services to address commercial
payers should be required to include
emergency services and intensive support
necessary to keep children out of
emergency rooms and able to access
ongoing services in the community my
daughter who spent a harrowing month at
Hamstead hospital and is now in
treatment out of state would currently
be home and in a lower level of care had
she had access to homebased therapeutic
services therapeutic education programs
and similar community services that have
been recommended to her at the earliest
sign that her condition was entering a
crisis stage I encourage the committee
to support for Senate Bill 411 and
ensure that commercial payers adequately
cover and finance Services desperately
needed by patients covered under this
commercial their commercial
plans and I have testimony from dein Ro
he's 18 years old my name is Dean Ro I'm
a resident of Bedford I'm writing in
support of sb41 I'm a college freshman
at the University of Southern Maine I'm
a brain cancer survivor a heart of
hearing person and many other things all
of which I am very proud but out of
every possible title or description I
could apply to myself I am most proud of
calling myself brother I'm writing to
you today because my 12-year-old sister
is suffering from mental illness after
several emergency room visits in October
and December of 2023 she ended up
spending a month at Hamstead hospital
and is now out of state at a therapeutic
residential school it did not have to be
this way she has been struggling for
years but her last school year was
particularly tough and she begged our
family for help that we could not find I
watched my parents struggle to find her
the support that she needed all while
her condition conditions steadily got
worse my sister has been hospitalized
multiple times we've had the police and
mobile crisis at our home it has been
hard to watch because it makes me and my
parents feel hopeless and unsafe instead
of focusing on studies at College during
my first semester I spent a lot of time
preoccupied and worried about what was
happening at home her condition was so
challenging that at Thanksgiving I
regretted my decision to come home for
that holiday we spent Christmas day not
together in our house with family and
loved ones but opening gifts in a
hospital emergency room I spend I
support s sp11 because the Bill calls
for emergency crisis services and
supports that my sister has needed for
far too long but couldn't get I'm
thankful to the fa fastforward staff for
the support they gave to my brother or
my sister and my parents over the past
few months and I'm relev to say that
she's currently safe in a program that
meets her needs but it's at of state and
it's still not enough and too often the
kinds of services people tell us that
our sister needs just don't exist or
have long waits in New Hampshire I need
my sister back I need her to feel like
herself again I need my parents to feel
supported and safe I need to focus on my
studies and be the big brother that I
want to be without worrying that every
phone call from home is going to be bad
news s sp411 would help many families
like mine to be sure that kids get the
help they need when they need
it as a pediatric cancer survivor I saw
firsthand how fast access to high
quality Care covered by Insurance made a
difference I would not be here today if
I didn't have the cancer treatment and
the system that operated like a mental
health and if I would not be here today
if the cancer treatment system operated
ated like our mental health system
especially considering what is going
through what going through my cancer and
the aftermath makes it look easy it's a
time that my sister got the same quality
of care compassion coverage and services
just like anyone else facing a
life-threatening health issue I hope you
will join me and my family in support of
s sp411 for kids like my sister who
deserve a chance at being healthy and
healing thank you for your time today
thank you any question
questions representative
McKay thank you Mr
chairman let let me try
again
the what I'm hearing from both of those
letters are the severe difficulties of
finding care when it's
needed and I'm hoping that the committee
that's studying this that seems to me
the primary
problem and resources are needed to
support those
programs but I would like us to
hear exactly what's going on now in
terms of
services provided by the state uh for
children 21 years and younger my
experience has been that that's a
seriously
neglected population do you have any
comments at all I sure um I think thank
you so much for that point I think
that's um exactly what this study
committee will be looking into is
identifying the gaps in what services
are available um through the lens of
insurance coverage and so uh we know
that when these services are offered
they are offered more to children with
Medicaid because they're able to be
reimbursed through Medicaid whereas
reimbursement may not be available
through private insurance and so if um
Insurance private insurance carriers
reimburse at the same rate as Medicaid
more services would be available and so
that lack of services that you've uh
identified um as being available and is
that is identified in these letters um
would in theory be equal uh between um
both the private and public
markets follow
up do you know what the state
is doing at this time to take care of
that uh lack of a facility availability
I know they bought a hospital for
children uh but I haven't heard any
reports as to how that's
going um specifically with how Hamstead
hospital is going I don't have specific
information um about that but I'm happy
to follow up on on how Hamstead Hospital
like the exact number of beds that are
available for
you any other questions representative
Merchant it's a question to the chair is
there going to be somebody from the
insurance department or somebody from
the insurance industry testifying I
think that's nhid I think that's New
Hampshire insurance department yeah here
thank you so
yes anyone else any other
questions seeing none thank you thank
also signed up to speak is Sam Hawkins
from Nami New Hampshire Nai New
minutes good afternoon chairman members
of the committee thank you for the
opportunity to testify today my name is
Sam Hawkins I'm the public policy
assistant at Nami New Hampshire the
National Alliance on Mental illness Nami
New Hampshire is a nonprofit Grassroots
organization whose mission is to improve
the lives of all people impacted by
mental illness and suicide through
support education and advocacy on behalf
of Nami New Hampshire I here today to
speak in strong support of Senate Bill
411 Nami New Hampshire is incredibly
grateful of everyone who has gotten
together to work on this issue through
the working group convened by the New
Hampshire insurance department however
is clear that more work and more study
is necessary specifically this
legislation gives us an opportunity to
look at coverage for High Fidelity
wraparound Services known in New
Hampshire as fast forward which are
intensive family focused services that
can prevent the necess necessity for
hospitalization when children and youth
are experiencing serious mental
emotional and behavioral concerns fast
forward provides Youth and Family driven
wraparound Services focused on helping
Youth and families identify their
strengths their needs develop a plan and
connect to services in their Community
as a provider of family peer support
services through this program Nami New
Hampshire can attest firsthand to its
positive imp
impact through the study that Senate
will 411 would enable New Hampshire can
look at the best way to pay for these
services and by expanding coverage and
providing additional avenues for access
to care services could be started
earlier on potentially alleviating the
need for hospitalization later cille 411
offers a crucial opportunity to look at
the systems and services available to
support our most vulnerable Youth and
address any gaps that may exist in
coverage so that youth can get access to
the services they need when and where
they need them for these reasons Nami
New Hampshire strongly ured is the
committee to vote OTP on Senate Bill 411
and I thank you for your time thank you
any
questions seeing that oh representative
chapero thank you Mr chairman
um so you seem to be acquainted and
through Nami part of the Fast Forward
program and um I'm just curious does the
fastforward program provide mainly or
solely care coordination in other words
connecting families with a
seriously um with someone with serious
mental
illness in their family to local
resources or does it actually
provide care beyond beyond um care
coordination I mean so does it actually
pay for and
provide um Family workers that go to
someone's house
um or um work with a child in the
community thank you for your question uh
n New Hampshire specifically provides
family peer support services through
fast Ford we're not involved in the
whole Suite of services uh involved in
fast Ford um our family peer support
services are largely uh supporting the
family through the whole Suite of
services and I do think fast forward is
largely care coordination but I would
defer to someone else to answer to the
full Suite of services thank you thank
you other questions
you also signed up to speak is Michelle
Heaton from the New Hampshire insur New
department good afternoon for the record
my name is Michelle heat and I'm the
director of Life and Health at the New
Hampshire insurance
department um as many people have
already testified this bill started off
as something a little bit different and
it started out more as an insurance
mandate um I do want to level set here
that mental health and Behavioral Health
Services for children are covered
benefits under Insurance in New
Hampshire um so we didn't believe that
there was uh there wasn't a reason to
put in this mandate because from our
view these services are already covered
however we recognize that there
obviously was some issue here and we
need to talk this through more so the
commissioner uh the insurance commission
put together a work group on this bill
sb411 and that's where we started um
having stakeholder
conversations I think at least once a
week for a while and that culminated in
US issuing a bulletin and during those
work sessions there was a lot of issues
being brought up one is insurance
coverage um I think there were also
issues with providers not being in
network there were issues about
Workforce there was a lot of issues
being brought up but what we were trying
to focus on with this bulletin that we
issued for 411 was the reimbursement
piece because these are services that
should be covered under insurance and it
seemed that there was some disconnect
between some of the providers and the
carriers as to how to properly build for
these services so we issued this
bulletin that directed carriers to work
with providers um and it identified a
list of different CPT and hpix codes
that would cover the bread of these
types of services that we're talking
about um and we encourage the carriers
to reach out to the providers and um
figure out if there are codes on the
that we identifi through this work group
that would be applicable that are not
part of Provider contracts currently
working with the providers to update
those contracts to make sure the
appropriate codes are in there so that
they can build for the services we also
found out through the work group that
there are a number of um service
providers that are not in network with
the different carriers so we directed
the parties to start talking and seeing
if there was a way for them to get into
Network and explore all different types
of reimbursement options not just V for
service so we issued the bulletin um at
the start of March and so it's our
understanding that work is underway we
have the insurance commissioner has also
um revived the behavioral health
advisory commission or committee that is
a committee under the Department of
Insurance that's specific to Commercial
Insurance and it's a committee full of
uh stakeholders in that industry and the
purpose of this committee is to get
together and talk through a lot of these
issues um so that we can work out any
kinks without having to do legislation
and if there are issues identified that
need to be resolved then they can advise
the commissioner about um what issues
they believe the insurance department
should look into take some kind of
regulatory action so we are actively
meeting and um our plan is to have the
carriers come at one of our meetings in
the near future to um talk about what
they've done in response to this
bulletin as well as another bulletin
that we had issued back in the fall so
that's a little bit of the background um
but I'm happy to take any questions any
Merchant thank you Mr chair and thank
you for taking the
question I want to keep help me
understand the insurance Market it's
large employers small employers there's
Medicaid Medicare there's many pieces to
the pie including in that pie is Arisa
and more and more plans are going to the
orisa model versus doing it through self
which is self-funded versus doing it
through small gr large groups would this
include Arisa
plans so Arisa it have to be care
careful because any group plan is bought
through your employer and that applies
to Arisa often times that term is used
to describe self-funded plans and no
this would not apply to self-funded
plans it would apply to employer group
plans that are commercial insurance so
if I'm looking at the pi is
100% what percentage of the pi is this
bill going to apply to Commercial
Insurance makes up about 30% of the
market
the rest of the market is Medicare
Medicaid TR care and self-funded you
know the commercial the commercial now
that 30% how much is that is self funded
no that's not including the self-funded
pie I am not sure I'd have to look that
up okay if you could because I was at a
meeting and what I was told was it
probably is about 18 to 19% of the
market actually we can control at the
state level or it's either the control
because ofisa or its governmental plans
and so forth and I just want to get
clarification I just want to be clear to
the committee to myself sort of level
setting expectations of what we can and
cannot do the other one too is in the
insurance department there is something
called
um adequacy if you will coverage so when
you're looking for certain Medical
Treatments or certain things like
prescriptions and whatnot there has to
be a certain level of adequacy for the
patient to have adequate access to that
care does that also translate into
mental health yes so our Network
adequacy requirements set the bare
minimum of um adequacy for having um
options available for services and that
applies to all plans all commercial
plans in New Hampshire and mental health
services are included in our Network
adequacy
requirements follow thank you so would
you be so kind is to let me know send me
an email or maybe the whole committee to
where I can find that adequacy coverage
because that's part of what I'm looking
for too is being sure that if we need to
it doesn't talk about adequacy coverage
here per se and I want to be sure that
we don't miss that opport are you
talking about like the rules related to
network adequacy the rules as well as
the law particularly the rules because
if the rules don't really apply to it
because we could have a lot of things
here this is really looking at more the
coverage but part of that underneath is
going to be the access issue of having
enough adequacy for the patient actually
get to a provider yes and I will couch
that
as Network adequacy puts into place the
minimum of who you need to have in
network However if those providers do
not exist in New Hampshire or are
unwilling to contract there is a way to
meet the adequacy of the network even
though those providers refuse to come
into Network it's kind of
um sorry it's the end of the day I'm
blanking on the word but it's
um if there are not enough providers in
the state insurers cannot create those
providers so that would not be counted
against them as them not having an
adequate Network as long as they are
attempting to contract with the ones
that are available thank you
representative Leon uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
with this information um I know that you
work with um part of the commercial
insurance Market um I'm just I'm trying
to understand if the self-pay stuff
would fall under this work that you've
already undertaken with stakeholders and
if it would fall underneath the special
the commiss committee that' be made by
the bill or if that would fall outside
them so the insurance department only
regulates the commercial insurance and
our laws only apply to Commercial
Insurance they do not apply to Medicare
Medicaid um or self-funded plans so I
believe this study committee is specific
to insurance so it would be stuff that
is within our purview and stuff that we
are actively working on thank you that
helps a lot representative
Murphy thank you Mr chairman and thank
you for taking my question so is it is
it fair to
say that um the insurance department is
opposed to the bill as it
stands in that you would prefer not to
have any legislation but to work
directly with the Prov providers with
the current legislation that's in in
effect right now we take no position um
and if you feel that this study
committee is necessary you know great go
ahead um but we do want to make sure you
know that these are issues we are
actively working on to the extent they
fall within um our domain of Regulation
and we are trying to convene
stakeholders to address a lot of these
issues however I think some of the stuff
that's being brought up about like fast
forward that is a Medicaid Program
program that is outside of our
jurisdiction followup so quick followup
so my question is I I thought I heard
you say that you would prefer not to
have any legislation done but would
prefer to work within the current
legislation that is out there that was
the um part of the reason why the
commissioner reestablished the
behavioral health advisory committee was
so that we could work on these Solutions
with stakeholders so that they didn't
have to bring legislation each time they
wanted to try to bring um address an
issue we wanted to try to be more
proactive get everyone in the room and
try to work out some of these issues
however if we identify something that
you know clearly needs a legislative fix
um you know we would be happy to work
with all the stakeholders and you know
bring that to everyone in the future
representative
McLean thank you Mr G just to be clear
th this study commission isn't going to
be looking at stuff like fast forward
and stuff like that right this is just
going to be looking at at coverage and
parity and things of that nature
correct I believe the way this the
legislation's currently written it says
that it's specific to health insurance
and coverage gaps under health insurance
but I know some of um the testimony
prior to me was talking about fast
forward and some of these other programs
the high fideli wraparound is part of
the Fast Forward which is a Medicaid
Program which includes social services
that are not MediCal Services that are
typically reimbursed by health insurance
so but it would not be studied as part
of this it does not believe so based on
what's
written other questions representative
Merchant follow up on representative
McLean's question if Medicaid is covered
which I think is 603 forward and that
seems to be working somewhat well I
think there some kinks in it that we
have to work through is there any logic
to kind of compare what the commercial
Market market doing compared to the
Medicaid Market to get a better sense of
which one's actually working fairly well
and if one's working better than the
other trying to understand what we need
gap they're very different programs with
very different purposes Medicaid is more
of a social has Social Service aspects
to it that health insurance does not
health insurance is a for for-profit
regulated market well not necessarily
for-profit but there's a profit aspect
associated with it in a regulatory
market and traditionally they have just
covered very different areas so um
that's one aspect of trying to get down
to the issues that could be explored
um I guess that's up to you guys to
figure out if that's what you want us to
do or not representative Missour yes
thank you Mr chair thank you for taking
my question so in looking at the duties
of this committee um it appears that so
lines 13 through uh 23 address um the
insurance questions that we've been
asking and it sounds to me like you've
answered a lot of them so the insurance
part is covered and then lines one and
then seven um address like the
behavioral health Gap so I'm wondering
if if those those two duties can be
encompassed
in the committee that representative
Shapiro mentioned earlier so would you
agree that that could be the case and
this bill might be redundant with what's
happening between you and that other
committee that was mentioned previously
I think a lot of these committees have
overlapping purposes and are working on
a lot of the same information and
include pretty much a lot of the same
stakeholders as well so I think there
um yeah I think I would defer to you
guys to figure out the best way to move
forward and I know um there were some
reasons why people thought this was more
of a specific purpose than some of the
other ones but I can see that there
could be some overlap representative
Weber I think actually the last
statement really got at the nub of what
my question was which was uh the issue
of specific examination versus a broader
approach to the
subject other
you also signed up to speak is Kristen
Shepard
thank
you we' asked for 5 to seven minutes if
you could shave that down a bit I'd
great good
afternoon members of the Health and
Human Service elderly Affairs committee
thank you for allowing me a moment of
your time my name is Kristen Shepard I'm
a registered voter and resident of
Daring New Hampshire I'm here today to
request not only the committee but each
and every person in this room to support
s
sp41 that will establish a committee to
study the state emergency Mental Health
Services for persons aged 20 years and
younger in the state of New Hampshire I
am a mother of a 20-year-old son who is
diagnosed with developmental
disabilities and significant mental
health issues including trauma and
psychosis my son is currently placed at
Mount Prospect Academy in Pike New
Hampshire where he's thriving and slated
to graduate high school in January of
2025 the state of the emergency Mental
Health Services in New Hampshire in all
honesty is
deplorable in May of 2021 my son began a
series of trips to local hospitals for
crisis mental health screenings the
first time we were sent there after our
son sat in an emergency room for a week
we were told we could take our son home
in order to quote board from home while
we waited for for a bed at Hamstead
hospital we quickly found out that this
was not true and there was no such
status as bored from home when
Christopher was discharged from the
emergency room he was also removed
permanently from the weight list for the
mental health bed at that hospital that
information came from Hamstead hospital
I spoke with them directly over the next
several months we returned to local
emergency rooms looking for help for
more times each time the weight
increased one week then a week and a
half then two weeks the second and third
time we we would bring our son home
after being told there was quote nothing
available finally the fource time fourth
time we refused to bring our son home
our son was having psychotic events
things were becoming scary at home he
was running away he was fighting demons
that weren't there he was hurting not
only myself but other family members
even trying to run through a picture
window in our
home at one point Christopher ran out of
the emergency room of Parkland with my
husband running after after him and not
one person on the staff of Parkland
responded my husband ran back inside to
tell them what happened because no one
seemed to see our son run away with his
six and 1 half foot father in chasing
right after him Christopher was found 2
miles from Parkland by the dairy police
department and return to the emergency
room within a week Christopher was
transferred to Portsmith Regional
Hospital in the secures pars unit once
at pars Christopher remained there for
another couple weeks bringing this most
recent trip to an ER to 30 days before a
bed became available at Hamstead
hospital this was 30 days without being
allowed to go outside this is 30 days
without being allowed to go to school or
see his friends this is 30 days of being
in a room alone not even knowing what
the weather was
outside these wait times are total
isolation and I'd like each of you to
turn to chap to page
four this picture is an individual in a
1946 I'd like you to look at page five
this is a picture I took of my son in
2021 the only thing different that we
can provide for mental health emergency
is a
difference are we really providing
better emergency Mental Health care
today we aren't my son was eventually
brought to Hamstead hospital and he
remained there for two weeks and
released home our family had been
working with Community Crossroads and
fast forwards at NFI Christopher wasn't
home long before returning to the
emergency room then back to Hamstead
hospital he was later found in need of
Residential Care Christopher needed a
level five residential care we don't
have one level five residential home in
the state of New Hampshire
over the years Christopher has had
individual therapy Psychiatric Services
therapeutic mentoring special ed
services family therapy Special Olympics
Boy Scouts and memberships to the Boys
and Girls Club of Greater Dairy just to
name a few things I fought for
everything I could for our son I knew
where to turn I knew what language to
use and how you ask because I'm a social
worker I hold a license in LCSW in four
states I have 30 years experience
working for the system within the system
and with the system I know the service
is in and out I know what's there and
what isn't I know what to ask for and
what to push for but still my family
went through hell my husband and I were
threatened to be filed on for neglect
because we refused to pick our son up
from an emergency
room my husband was told he had to leave
an emergency room because he was
aerating our son's issues I heard a
security guard telling this consider
outside of my room in the middle of the
night one time these parents need to
take their out of control children home
and deal with the bad behavior my
husband and I were thrilled that our we
were told that our residential program
was located for our son but sad when it
was out of state we were horrified to
find out the residential was in
Mississippi did you know you cannot get
to Mississippi directly from anywhere in
New England not just New Hampshire the
insurance company refused to pay for
anything and we refused to put them on a
commercial
$2,822 on a med flight to get our son
safely to Mississippi so that he would
not have any psychotic events while on a
commercial flight and bringing TSA
involved so not only as a mother but as
a social worker I asked for each of you
to support sb411 our children deserve
better care and families need better
support when faced with a mental health
crisis I'd be happy to answer any
questions thank you representative
Shapiro thank you Mr chairman so I'm
wondering if if you attribute any of the
difficulties that your son had in
receiving appropriate care with the fact
that they had a developmental disability
as well as a psychiatric illness
yes I I I think there there's a big
combination of it
absolutely thank you representative
McKay thank you Mr chairman uh thank you
for your testimony you you probably
heard me
complaining and you you answered my
questions by pointing out your own
experience and plus as a social worker
and some of us here are also social
workers
um I'm not against this bill but
I'm what's getting to me is we're
talking about peripheral issues and not
about the basic issue which is lack of
services and I'm not critical of the
department either but I I would like to
know maybe it's in um the committee that
was mentioned maybe that's what they're
going to do uh I'm hopeful but that I am
very
concerned about what you're talking
about and that is that services are not
available to some of the most vulnerable
yes people in our society and that the
legislature needs to know that and and
and not the full you have a question
represent would you
believe that the importance of insurance
is
extremely uh
significant but that the insurance is
not useful if there's nothing to buy
that there's no Services there and we
need to know uh and frankly we're we're
ahead of where we were
but we're still hearing things that are
disturbing to me and I think the
legislature needs to know this thank you
very much thank you other questions
representative Seth King thank you Mr
chair thank you for sharing your
testimony very sorry to hear all
that I'm curious I'm not terribly
familiar with our entire system and
what what things are available for
people I'm just curious maybe you know
maybe you don't um a lot of this sounds
like it costed a lot of money doesn't
sound like the quality of care was all
that great and I'm just curious could
parents just relinquish their children
to be Wards of the state is that a thing
and and if they
were would the would the quality of care
be any less than what you received and
would you still be able to visit your
son I I just I'm I'm just curious could
it get any worse than it is and if you
were just
to you know or or does the state kick
people out onto the streets when they
have the types of conditions your son
does I just if you could shine a light
on any of that for me that'd be great so
our son is adopted from the foster care
system he moved in with us when he was
four and a half we adopted him a year
later um I don't want to Pat us on on
the
back but what the state of Massachusetts
got was a therapeutic home from us and
had we not adopted him I will guarantee
you that child will e would either a be
in a group home residential home for the
rest of his life or he would be out on
answer as a social worker I did 18 years
of child protection in the state of Mass
CH it's and I can't tell you how many
children were returned back to the state
exactly for that they needed more
services and parents didn't know what to
do my story my family story this is not
unique there this this story is the same
over and over again just a different
last name um at one point my husband and
I had considered it it was a very brief
consideration just because we wanted to
keep him safe he was said 17 he was
acting out and he was at an age if he
hurt somebody he was going to go to jail
and then what
happens he's just going to be taken
advantage of
so when we refused to bring him home it
was so that we could get the services
but a lot of parents are bullied by the
system and are forced to take these kids
home and then DCF or dcyf here gets
involved um
so to answer your question it could it
could get a lot worse and it does for
some families um I own a private
practice I do tele Health in four states
and I take phone calls all the time from
people parents asking I don't know what
to do and I just try to steer them in
the right direction on who to call what
to do and sometimes there in States I I
don't I've never worked in so I'm online
Googling as much information as I can
about that state to learn as fast as I
is thank you other
questions seeing no other questions
thank you thank
you uh representative Shapiro could I
Prevail on you one more time for the
blue sheet representative Weber you
offered last week to look up on the
online for me would you be willing to do
support okay three in support no one
you I have no other pink cards does
hi Michelle Merritt I'm back again from
new Futures there were a couple of
questions that I thought I might be able
to help answer particularly around the
Behavioral Health crisis commission what
the scope of that commission is um I sit
on it uh along with representative
Shapiro and representative Merchant um
there is not overlap in the duties and
responsibilities of that commission with
what we're talking about with this
particular piece of legislation that
bill is narrow to be looking at the
financing for the 988 system which is a
crisis hotline um and to determine how
the state can continue funding it
because federal funds are lapsing it
really is not in the the realm of the
duties and the scope of that commission
to be looking at crisis services and
functional supports and the the parody
difference between private insurance and
Medicaid for the children's Behavioral
Health System um they have a very narrow
scope of responsibilities and there is
in my view there is really not not any
overlap in the the duties of those two
groups so in the event there were
questions about that I thought I might
be able to help answer those because I
sit on it thank you very much
representative
Weber uh from the um signin there are
142 in support and one opposed and
actually I'm paging down here and I'm
not actually seeing the one that is
opposed oh I got it y
right thank you very
much okay uh with that I'm going to
close the public hearing on Senate Bill
411 FN that concludes all of the public
hearings and actually all of the bills
we have we need to have public hearings
for from the Senate uh our public
hearing schedule is now complete and